Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 157. Mein Name Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch an den Hörgeräten. Und heute geht es nicht wie im Internet kolportiert um Seidenmalerei. Vielleicht greife ich das Thema später noch mal auf. Nein, heute möchte ich mich einer kulturellen Ausgabe widmen, nachdem wir jetzt auch wieder viel Technik dran gehabt haben. Bisschen Technik kommt vielleicht zur Sprache, aber im Kern geht es nicht darum, sondern im Mittelpunkt des Gesprächs steht schlicht Fernsehen. Ich finde, da muss mal drüber gesprochen werden. Und ich dachte mir, das könnte man ganz super machen mit Holger. Holger Kreymeier, hallo.
Hallo.
Willkommen bei Chaosradio Express. Und ja, dich habe ich mal angesprochen, ob wir nicht mal ein bisschen schwatzen könnten über das Thema, weil du, also nicht nur, aber vor allem, weil du seit wie lange eigentlich, seit zwei Jahren oder so, wie lange läuft das Programm jetzt? fernsehkritik.tv?
Das Magazin gibt es seit April 2007, also schon mehr als drei Jahre.
Ah, okay, gut. Dann habe ich es nicht von Anfang an mitgeschnitten. Aber es wird kontinuierlich weiter produziert. Also das Magazin ist eine 20, na, was ist das für eine mittlere Sendedauer?
Halbe Stunde eigentlich Minimum.
Halbe Stunde Minimum, kann auch mal länger sein. Und das gibt es dann irgendwie als Podcast und im Web.
Und als downloadbare Quicktime-Version. Genau. Für die Leute auf dem Land.
Ja, und ja, da greifst du quasi das Geschehen im Fernsehen auf. Also im deutschen Fernsehen natürlich vor allem. Oder gibt's da auch mal einen Blick über den Tellerrand.
Im deutschsprachigen Raum. Also Österreich und Schweiz war auch schon Thema.
Ja, stimmt, genau. Insbesondere was das leidige CRE-Thema betrifft, da kommen wir sicherlich noch drauf. Aber was mich natürlich zunächst mal interessieren würde, ist wie kommst du eigentlich dazu? Bist du so eine Crouch-Potato?
Nee, also das eigentlich weniger. Also ich bin ja seit Mitte der 90er Jahre selbst im Medienbereich tätig. Ich habe beim Radio ein bisschen was gemacht, ich print und habe auch Fernseherfahrungen gesammelt. Und 2003 habe ich ein halbes Jahr lang, da bin ich über Umwege reingerutscht, plötzlich Boulevardfernsehen gemacht. Und ja, habe im Grunde genommen die Schattenseiten von Fernsehen.
Kannst du auch sagen, was?
Das war vom Springer Verlag eine Agentur für exklusiv Fernsehmaterial. Weil der Diegmann von der Bild hat damals immer gesagt, er hat sich immer aufgeregt, die Leute vom Fernsehen lesen immer alle unsere Zeitung und dann kreien sie sich immer alle unsere Stories und machen daraus Fernsehen. Und wir machen das jetzt mal so, wir machen das einen Tag vorher die Leute schon klar, drehen das selber und verkaufen es dann den Sendern. Also es war sozusagen deren Konzept. Und ich bin also als Redakteur damit reingerutscht und ja, hab im Grunde genommen feststellen müssen, wie brutal Fernsehen sein kann, wie sehr menschliche Schicksale eine Ware sind. Also ich musste Leute anrufen, die was weiß ich für schwere Schicksale gerade erlitten haben, Kinder totgefahren oder was. Und die Eltern soll ich anrufen und die fragen, ob sie ein Interview dazu geben möchten fürs Fernsehen und solche Sachen. Und ja, das hat mich ein halbes Jahr lang begleitet. Dann war Feierabend, habe ich gesagt, das mache ich nicht mehr, jetzt höre ich hier auf. Ich habe keinen Bock mehr dazu. Ich habe ja vor auch Soziologie studiert. Ich habe mich mit Medien auseinandergesetzt. Das war sogar mein Schwerpunkt. Ich hätte es eigentlich besser wissen müssen. Aber man muss dazu wissen, die Mutterfirma dieser Agentur war Spiegel TV. Also die haben mit Springer da zusammengearbeitet. Ich war natürlich so naiv zu glauben, Spiegel TV wäre ein seriöser Name. So schlimm kann es nicht werden. Aber es war unterste Schublade. Und das war auch, glaube ich, für mich der Anfang, dass ich wirklich gesagt habe, das muss man öffentlich machen. Da muss man den Leuten mitteilen, was hinter den Kulissen des Fernsehens abgeht und wie brutal Fernsehen eigentlich ist. Und so ist die Seite Fernsehkritik TV entstanden. Die ist unmittelbar nach Ende dieser Beschäftigung dort ins Leben gerufen worden, 2003. Und bestand dann drei, vier Jahre nur aus Texten. Und ich war dann irgendwann an dem Punkt, dass ich gesagt habe, es macht eigentlich mehr Sinn, den Leuten das auch wirklich zu zeigen, was ich meine und nicht nur darüber zu schreiben. Das ist auch besser vermittelbar. Und so ist dann eben dieses Magazin entstanden.
Aber so im Fernsehbusiness als solchen bist du dann erst mal nicht geblieben?
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Als ich beim NDR bin ich gewesen, nebenbei noch, aber das war nie direkt Fernsehen. Ich habe nur Untertitel für Gehörlose fürs Fernsehen zum Beispiel gemacht und habe im Online-Bereich vom NDR gearbeitet. Also eine Meldung für ndr.de geschrieben und so was. Aber da kenne ich Fernsehen direkt.
Und jetzt bist du auch komplett im unabhängigen Sektor?
Jetzt bin ich komplett, genau. Der NDR hat mich ja gefeuert letztes Jahr, weil ich ja diese Kampagne, dafür zahle ich nicht, ins Leben gerufen hatte. Und da hat der NDR gesagt, das ist nicht vereinbar, auch nicht mit der freien Mitarbeit beim NDR. Aber das hat mich ja noch umso freier noch gemacht. Es war immer so ein bisschen böse. Ich dachte, naja, du bist beim NDR tätig, nebenbei machst du diese Geschichte. Er beißt dich schon ein bisschen.
Was heißt das? Warst du ganz froh, dass die Entscheidung abgenommen wurde?
Es war eine finanzielle Quelle für mich, keine Frage. Das war, wobei ich auch gerechnet habe mit dem Geld jeden Monat. Aber ich habe das mittlerweile schnell ausgeglichen bekommen. Und ich vermisse da nichts mehr. Bin froh, dass ich da weg bin.
Dafür zahle ich nicht. Das bezieht sich auf die GEZ.
Ja, es bezieht sich auf die Programm-Inhalte. Also viele verstehen es immer so, als wenn ich damit meine Leute zahlt, kann die GEZ-Gebühr. Aber ich gebe ihnen bei dieser Kampagne Beispiele, Daily Soaps und diese ganzen seichten Dinge und niveaulosen Dinge im Fernsehen. Und sage dann eben, dafür zahle ich aber keine Gebühren. So ist es gemeint. Und das hatte der NDR auch etwas missverstanden, glaube ich.
Bevor wir da jetzt voll hier das deutsche Fernsehen in den Mittelpunkt stellen, würde ich da vielleicht ganz gerne noch mal so ein bisschen weiter zurückspulen. Ich meine, du bist ja wahrscheinlich auch mit Fernsehen groß geworden. Also ich muss dazu sagen, ich bin selber so, deswegen hat mich das jetzt eigentlich auch das Thema so interessiert. Ich hab also früher als Kind auch viel Fernsehen geguckt, definitiv auch wahrscheinlich zu viel, wie die meisten wahrscheinlich auch. Und irgendwann wurde das dann aber, glaube ich, vom Internet im Wesentlichen übernommen. Das ist schon lange her. Und jetzt blicke ich schon auf so eine so lange absolute Zeit zurück, dass ich schon fast gar nicht mehr weiß, wie lang die eigentlich ist. Das heißt, ich habe eine extreme Distanz zu diesem ganzen Kram. Insofern war es für mich ganz interessant, auf fernsehkritik.tv zu stoßen, sozusagen dieses Fenster geöffnet zu bekommen. So, oh, super, man muss jetzt, ja, so ein bisschen wie so ein Geschirrspüler, nicht? Der wäscht für einen das Geschirr und fernsehkritik.tv schaut sich für einen das Programm an. Und das nicht die ganze Sputzengewäsche wird da sozusagen gleich sortiert.
Den Dreck abwaschen muss ich, ja, genau.
Aber was hast du da sozusagen selbst für dich als Sozialisierung mitgenommen?
Also bei uns lief während meiner Kindheit jeden Abend der Fernseher. Meine Eltern gucken bis heute sehr viel Fernsehen. Wobei mein Vater, auch wenn ich in recht einfachen Verhältnissen so groß geworden bin, mein Vater aber immer eine kritische Haltung hatte zu jeglichen Heimatfilmen und solchen Kram, das hat er nie gemacht. Also bei uns gab es schon eher so, dass der Tatort geguckt wurde. Also meine Eltern haben jetzt nicht darauf geachtet, ob ich viel oder wenig Fernsehen gucke. Ich habe den Fernseher selber angemacht und durfte das und das war nie ein Thema. Es war damals aber auch ja so, dass tagsüber das Fernsehen überhaupt nicht lief. Da gab es ja nur ein Testbild und das Fernsehen war ja auch damals viel verantwortlicher als heute.
Damals, wovon reden wir jetzt?
Wir reden jetzt vor, würde ich mal sagen, Ende der 70er, Anfang der 80er Jahre.
Als das Fernsehen noch ein Ende hatte.
Jaja, absolut. Also es gab...
Sendeschluss, das ist ein Wort, das gar nicht mehr, ne?
Der Sendeschluss, genau. Es gab mittags zwischen 12 und 16 Uhr wurde eine Pause gemacht. Da gab es einen Videotext für alle, weil Videotext war damals ja auch...
War das auch eine Mittagspause in den 70ern?
Jaja, jaja. Es gab damals ja Videotext ganz neu und es konnten aber nur Leute empfangen, die einen speziellen Decoder hatten. Das ist nicht wie heute, das ist in jedem Fernseher drüber. Und dann gab es zwischendurch Videotext für alle. Da konnten dann alle mal Videotext gucken. Der war aber natürlich nicht interaktiv, sondern die Seiten sind von selber umgeschlagen, wie so eine Zeitung.
Stimmt, das haben sie auch dann nach Sendeschluss teilweise gemacht.
Jaja, genau, genau.
Das ist ja so das Äquivalent zum Internet-Ausdrucken, nicht so?
Ja, und am Nachmittag gab es dann eben auch Kinderprogramme. Es gab ja keinen Kinderkanal und nichts. Und das war natürlich auch sehr verantwortliches Kinderprogramm. Peter Lustig und Die Biene Maja und so. Also wenn ich mir vorstelle, heutzutage, da läuft mittags um eins dann irgendwie Brit, die dann über sexuelle Abarten diskutiert und da sitzen Kinder vor dem Fernseher. Also das war damals schon noch eine goldene, heile Welt des Fernsehens, möchte ich mal so ein bisschen sagen. Vielleicht hat man so ein bisschen verklärte Erinnerungen, weiß ich nicht.
Aber das kann gut sein, oder?
Aber ich jedenfalls bin ich froh, dass ich als Kind das Fernsehen geguckt habe und nicht als Kind heutzutage vielleicht Fernsehen gucken müsste oder gucken würde. Ich glaube, das hat einen schlechten Einfluss.
Aber früher war ja immer alles besser, ne? Sagt man so, ja. Kann ja auch sein, dass unsere Zeit da schon unerträglich war eigentlich, ne?
Ja, natürlich. Also es gab auch damals viel, sage ich das Programm, es gab auch im Showbereich viele, viele alberne Sendungen. Auch der Peter Alexander wird heute immer so hoch gejubelt. Wenn man sich diese Sendung so anschaut rückblickend, waren die auch recht albern eigentlich. Das waren billige Witze, wurden da gerissen, Sketche und so.
Kuhnenkampf.
Ja, auch Kuhnenkampf finde ich toll.
Kuhnenkampf fand ich auch toll.
Ja, ich bin immer, ich hab die ganz viele EWG-Sendungen auf DVD mir besorgt.
Aus einer wird gewinnen.
Ja, einer wird gewinnen, genau. Der Mann hatte einfach Niveau und der war intelligent und hat trotzdem den nötigen Witz gehabt. Das war eine großartige Sendung, also sehe ich mir heute noch gerne an. Oder der Große Preis war auch, das sind für mich so Sendungen, die auch öffentlich-rechtlichen Charakter haben, weil sie unterhaltsam sind, aber trotzdem auch Bildung vermittelt haben.
Eine Samstagabends-Show, in der L'Oreal den regelmäßigen Komedianten gab, das muss man sich auch noch mal in den Inneren rufen.
Welche meinst du jetzt?
Na, der Große Preis.
Achso, der lief am Donnerstagabend, wenn ich dich belehren darf. Der berühmte, 1930 Donnerstagabend, Sendeplatz im ZDF, Dali Dali und der Große Preis. Du meinst jetzt, wo man wendet, mit dem wir den Zeichentrick filmen.
Genau, das meinte ich. Ich meine, das kann man sich jetzt so nicht... Abgesehen davon, dass mir kein Komediant von dem Format einfallen würde, würde mir jetzt auch keine andere Mischung in der Form einfallen.
Das stimmt, das war was Besonderes.
Ja, aber was denkst du denn sozusagen? War das dann sozusagen gut, das alles zu sehen und zur Kenntnis zu nehmen? Ich meine, wir haben jetzt beide nicht so richtig den Vergleich zu der Zeit mit ohne Fernsehen. Auch wenn man sagen muss, wie Fernsehen heute ist, da war das damals ja eigentlich schon fast ohne. Es gab irgendwie drei Programme, erst zwei, dann drei. Und ja, und ein Sendeschluss und auch ein Sendeanfang und das war's. Abgesehen davon, dass es dann bestenfalls auch nur einen Fernseher im Haushalt gab, weil man das Gefühl hat, dass heute jedes Gerät schon mit einem eigenen Empfangsgerät daherkommt, anschließend des Kühlschranks.
Ja, vor allem auch mal ein Video-Recorder war ja auch noch Luxus zu der Zeit.
Oh ja.
Und man konnte auch keine Alternativprogramme zum Fernsehen sich anschauen. Muss man ja auch dazu wissen. Also entweder schaute man sich das Fernsehen an oder man schaltete ab, so.
Ja, insofern hat ja Fernsehen auch eine interessante kulturelle Änderung mit sich gebracht, weil es gab das eine über das alle, was sie alle haben, so mitnehmen. Okay, es gab das eine und das andere, aber es gab dann irgendwie kaum noch was Drittes und es gab definitiv immer so das eine, worauf sich eigentlich alles fokussiert hat. Also wenn da mal zwei Sachen über die alle redeten kamen, dann war das wahrscheinlich auch schon was Besonderes.
Ja, sicher, Sendungen wie EWG und Großer Preis, die hatten 20 Millionen Zuschauer und noch mehr. Also Marktanteile 70, 80 Prozent. Das schafft heute nur noch ein WM-Spiel, wenn Deutschland spielt. Sonst ist das ja, die vielen Sender teilen das ja unter sich auf, natürlich diesen Marktanteilskuchen. Und insofern war das damals auch ein wirklich großes Gesprächsthema. Und es gab damals natürlich auch die richtigen großen Fernsehprominenten, weil eben die jeder auch wirklich kannte, weil die wirklich so in so viele Haushalte jeden Abend gekommen sind. Also hat sich auch was verändert.
Ich habe auch mal eine Podcast-Serie gemacht mit der Aktion Mensch. Und da erinnere ich mich jetzt gerade noch dran, dass es ja mal gestartet als die Aktion Sorgenkind. Und das war ja dann quasi von dem ZDF oder aus dem Kontext ZDF heraus initiiertes Ding. Damals auch noch so mit dem Anspruch, wir zeigen jetzt mal der Öffentlichkeit, dass Fernsehen auch zu was Gutem da ist. Ja, dass wir sozusagen hier auch der Gesellschaft etwas zurückgeben können. Die Feststellung damals von der Sprecherin von Aktion Mensch fand ich insofern ganz interessant, als dass mir nicht so ganz bewusst gewesen ist, wie das Selbstverständnis des Fernsehens damals denn so gewesen ist. Weil es natürlich ja ohnehin schon als Bildungsauftrag und so weiter und wir müssen hier Nachrichten verbreiten und Qualitätsfernsehen machen, la la la. Also den Begriff Qualitätsfernsehen gab es natürlich so noch nicht, aber es war halt klar, man hat diese Institutionen aus der Taufe gehoben, um eben Programme zu schaffen für die geblendeten Massen. Und das sollte ja gut sein, aber offensichtlich war die Wahrnehmung, entweder die Außenwahrnehmung oder auch die Innenwahrnehmung von den Sendern selbst zu dem Zeitpunkt noch gar nicht so ausgeprägt. Wie hast du denn das in Erinnerung? Ich meine, war, da muss man jetzt auch nicht in 70er Jahren hängen bleiben, so also, wann hast du das das erste Mal darüber nachgedacht? Ich weiß es nicht, aber was denkst du darüber, wie sich das Fernsehen am Anfang selbst gesehen hat?
Ja, das Fernsehen hatte, und das ist ja auch bis heute im Rundfunkstaatsvertrag so fest geschrieben, einen Bildungs- und Kulturauftrag. Und der ist damals auch sehr viel strenger wahrgenommen worden als heute. Also vor kurzem war der Dieter Wedel in einer Talkshow, der ja seit über 30 Jahren Fernsehfilme in Deutschland macht. Und der erzählte, dass damals in 70er Jahren hatte er diesen berühmten Film mit der Familie Semmeling gemacht, mit diesem Hausbau. Und am nächsten Morgen der Programmchef zu ihm kam und sagte...
Kannst du nochmal sagen, weil das nicht berühmt genug ist, dass es mir in Erinnerung geblieben wäre?
Also es gab diese Familie Semmeling, da hat er drei Teile gemacht, der hieß Einmal im Leben, wo sie ein eigenes Haus bauen. Das ist ein TV-Film, Klassiker. Und er hat dann nochmal einen zweiten Film mit denen gemacht, mit dieser Familie, das hieß... Da sind sie in den Urlaub geflogen, haben Urlaub irgendwie Ärger gehabt. Das ging immer so darum, Ärger mit Behörden und Ärger mit Urlaubsveranstaltern.
Aber nicht eine richtige Familie, die sozusagen begleitet wurde?
Nein, nein, das waren Schauspieler, natürlich. Das waren Fernsehfilme, man fliegt über Fernsehfilme. Und der macht ja bis heute auch eben Fernsehfilme. Er hat vor kurzem diesen Gier gemacht mit Ulrich Thucour, diesen Zweiteiler. Und er erzählte eben, dass damals dieser Programmdirektor auf ihn zukam, am Morgen nach der Ausstrahlung und sagte, war ja ein sehr schöner Film, Herr Wedel, leider zu populär. Also er meinte, damit die Quoten waren zu gut. Also damals war die Einstellung wirklich, wenn die Leute, die Massen das gucken, dann ist es ein scheiß Mindstream-Programm. Das kann nicht gut gewesen sein. Und so hat sich halt die Einstellung beim Fernsehen so verändert. Ich bin ja bei Presseverteiler von ARD und ZDF. Ich kriege ja fast jeden Tag deren Quotenmeldung. Und immer wird gesagt, gestern wieder Fußball. Und wer denn das hatte wieder eine Top-Quote. Und das stärkt wieder den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk. Weil damit zeigt sich, die Leute mögen ARD und ZDF. Und so wird heute argumentiert. Also da zeigt sich was, das hat einen totalen Paradigmenwechsel da gegeben in der Hinsicht. Ja, aber ich glaube, dass die Wahrheit muss natürlich irgendwo in der Mitte liegen. Ich meine, natürlich ist es Quatsch zu sagen, alles, was die hohe Quoten hat, ist blöd. Sondern es muss bei den Leuten ankommen. Es muss aber trotzdem auch verantwortlich sein. Und in der Tat sollten ARD und ZDF, dafür kriegen sie ihre Gebühren, ihren Bildungs- und Kulturauftrag immer mitdenken. Und das ist damals mehr geschehen als heute.
Wann hast du denn angefangen, mal jetzt abgesehen von deiner professionellen Laufbahn, die du da schon angesprochen hast, wo es dann so diesen Wechsel gab. Aber meine Fernsehen musste ich ja auch fasziniert haben. Sonst, denke ich mal, fängt man mit so was nicht an. Was war die Faszination?
Ja, die Faszination von Fernsehen ist, glaube ich, dass man einfach, es spricht ja alle Sinne an. Also man sieht, man hört und man kann sich davor setzen und sich berieseln lassen. Wenn man liest, ist es ja sehr viel anstrengender. Oder wenn man vielleicht nur Radio hört, dann muss man das aufs Ohr fokussieren. Fernsehen ist einfach ein Medium, was einfach so rüberkommt, als wenn man im realen Leben mit jemandem spricht vielleicht oder eine Situation beobachtet, die direkt vor einem stattfindet. Heutzutage noch mehr durch HD und so als früher. Ja, und dadurch hat man als Kind natürlich auch in so eine Fantasiewelt schnell eingestiegen, mit Biene Maya und mit Pinocchio und so weiter. Das hat mich als Kind mehr angesprochen, als wenn ich jetzt ein Kinderbuch gelesen habe oder ein Bilderbuch mir angeschaut habe. Und deswegen ist ja heutzutage bei Kindern wiederum die nächste Stufe, sind dann diese Video Games und so. Das spricht Kinder einfach an. Das ist wie Süßigkeiten im multimedialen Bereich. Das ist einfach toll, das fasziniert. Und so war das damals auch schon.
Immersion fällt mir dazu ein, dieses komplett Eingenommenwerden von dem Medium. Das ist wahrscheinlich die Steigerung beim Videospiel, dass es einfach mal noch realer ist, dreidimensionaler, bis hin zu selber eine Rolle spielen natürlich.
Und irgendwann kommen wir vielleicht sogar in Richtung Cyberspace, wenn es ist die komplette Illusion.
Videospiel ist eigentlich dieses interaktive Fernsehen, von dem sie immer alle geredet haben, fällt mir gerade ein.
Ja, natürlich, auf jeden Fall. Wobei natürlich...
Aber interaktives Fernsehen selber war der totale Flop, weil die Leute wollen ja eigentlich gar nicht interaktiv sein.
Also zum Beispiel bei Formel 1 damals, bei Premiere, das fand ich ja sowieso albern, zu sagen, sie können selber den Regisseur machen und das jeweilige, die Kamera in jedem Cockpit von Schumi sich angucken auf Knopfdruck oder die Kurve da auf der Kamera. Ich meine, dafür habe ich ja den Regisseur, dass der genau in dem Moment dort ist, wo ich sehen will, wo was passiert. Also das habe ich damals schon nicht verstanden. War auch nicht sehr erfolgreich, glaube ich. Also interaktiv muss halt immer bedeuten, natürlich oder bedeutet nicht, dass mir sozusagen die Arbeit des Regisseurs abgenommen wird. Weil ich meine, jetzt zum Beispiel bei der WM, wenn Gerhard Delling da mit diesem Touchscreen da andauernd diese ganzen Szenen selber einspielen muss und dann ist er da vor und zurückspulen, dafür gibt es eine Regie. Was soll das? Das ist technische Spielerei. Die ist einfach albern. Also das ist auch eine indirekte iPad-Werbung offensichtlich schon wieder.
Also ja, da fasse ich mir auch mal ein bisschen den Kopf. Das fing ja schon mit diesen Wahlsendungen an. Okay, ich meine, da mag es noch in gewisser Hinsicht sinnvoll sein, weil man davon sagen kann, okay, in dem Gespräch sollte es jetzt wirklich so sein. Ergibt sich ein neuer Gedanke, lass uns doch mal das anschauen. Aber ich glaube halt auch nicht da dran, dass diese Entscheidungen wirklich in dem Moment in diesem Dialog gefällt werden sollen. Die stehen ja schon vorher fest. Von daher hast du ganz recht, kann man es auch gleich der Regie überlassen. So, das heißt, okay, also das mit der Immersion, das verstehe ich, da so reingezogen zu werden. Irgendwann, also bei mir hat dann halt auch irgendwann eine Überforderung eingesetzt. Also irgendwann habe ich auch gemerkt, so, oh Gott, ich verbringe jetzt hier meine Zeit in diesem Apparat, so. Und du hast ja in deiner Sendung, in deinem Magazin, wenn du so schön sagst, diesen wunderbaren Spruch, schalten sie mal wieder ab. Ganz großartig. Ich habe ehrlich gesagt, ich habe den Eindruck, dass in dem Moment, wo ich vor dem Fernseher sitze, dass ich eigentlich schon abschalte. Weißt du, was ich meine? Also dass man einfach selber jeglichen aktiven Gedanken eigentlich fallen lässt, so und irgendwie weg ist. Und es gibt ja auch diesen schönen Begriff mit lean back und lean forward Medium. Beim Fernsehen legt man sich halt zurück ins Sofa, beim Internet lehnt man sich irgendwie nach vorne und schaut sozusagen in den Bildschirm und ist sozusagen mehr so ein hin. Oder wie Steve Jobs das mal so schön gesagt hat, TV ist meant to turn your brain off und Internet, Computers are meant to turn your brain on. Geht dir das nicht so?
Doch, doch, das ist vollkommen richtig. Weil das Fernsehen erledigt für einen ja alles. Man muss ja nur gucken und sich zurücklehnen und hat das direkt drauf an der Nase. Und deswegen, das ist vollkommen richtig. Und das war als Kind halt, war das auch schon so. Aber es ist als Erwachsener heute immer noch so. Das Fernsehen ist bloß noch lauter geworden und krawalliger geworden. Aber daran haben die Leute sich mittlerweile ja offenbar auch schon gewöhnt. Also es ist auch ein Gewöhnungsprozess, der da stattfindet. Also es ist auch vielleicht eine Art von Gehirnwäsche. Und das ist dann wiederum auch eine gefährliche Entwicklung. Wenn ich dieses Magazin nicht machen würde, hätte ich vielleicht mein Fernseher schon abgeschafft. Ich weiß es nicht. Wobei abgeschafft nicht, aber weil ich mir schon gern noch DVDs und Blu-rays ansehe. Ich weiß ja trotzdem, dass Millionen andere das gucken. Und deswegen ist es für mich auch eine Art Mission, jetzt mit diesem Magazin auch immer wieder zu versuchen, Leute zu erreichen. Es gibt ja Intellektuelle, die mir so ein bisschen vorwerfen, dass es zu flach ist, wie du das machst. Das ist nicht intellektuell genug. Du musst medientheoretischer werden, medientkritischer werden. Ja, nur denn rennen mir die ganzen Leute weg, die ich ja eigentlich erreichen will. Also gibt es diesen schönen Spruch von Hugo von Hoffmannstal, man muss das Tiefgründige an der Oberfläche verstecken. Und das ist genau mein Leitspruch, dass ich sage, ich möchte ja gern vor allem Leute erreichen, die sich vielleicht über Fernsehen bisher nicht so viel Gedanken gemacht haben. Und da ich immer wieder Feedback von Jugendlichen vor allem bekomme, die dann auch schreiben, dass sie einen anderen Blick aufs Fernsehen bekommen haben, durch dieses Magazin, ist es ja auch durchaus erfolgreich.
Stimmt, das hast du in einer der Ausgaben auch mal erwähnt, oder mindestens in einer. Hast du denn eine Erkenntnis darüber, wer dir so zuschaut? Sind das im Wesentlichen junge Leute?
Ja, also ich hab mal eine kleine Erhebung gemacht und da stellte sich in der Tat heraus, dass so ungefähr zwei Drittel also nicht älter als 22, 23 sind. Das wird sehr stark von Jugendlichen und jungen Erwachsenen genutzt, aber hat wohl auch mit deren Nutzerverhalten einfach zu tun. Also die Generation 30 plus, die ist es halt nicht so gewohnt vielleicht, sich eine dreiviertel Stunde lang vom Computerbildschirm, so einen Magazin anzuschauen. Die sagen sich, das ist mir zu anstrengend. Im Fernsehen würde ich es gucken, aber so vom Internet, vom Computerbildschirm, ist glaube ich einfach eine Frage der Gewohnheit des Nutzerverhaltens. Also hat wohl auch damit zu tun.
Aber so diese Mix-Medien-Geschichte, denke ich, ist in der Jugend jetzt auch schon durch. Also das muss man glaube ich gar nicht weiter drüber diskutieren. Das heißt, du sprichst im Wesentlichen junge Leute an, also nicht, dass du es jetzt primär machst. Ich meine, was mich immer ein bisschen verstört ist, dass du halt immer alle siehst.
Und das finde ich auch, das ist für mich der Respekt vor dem Zuschauer. Ich finde, man muss dieses geduzt, das geht mir auch auf die Nerven.
Also hier wird ja geduzt.
Ja, das ist ja in Ordnung. Aber das haben wir auch in einem Vernehmen, machen wir das ja auch. Aber ich duze ja den Zuschauer nicht, ich habe ihn ja vorher nicht jeden einzelnen gefragt, darf ich die duzen oder darf ich sie duzen, sondern dann tue ich das einfach. Ich finde, man kann auch gewisse Umgangsformen einfach mal wahren. Das mag ein bisschen konservativ klingen, aber da bin ich dann vielleicht ein bisschen konservativ.
Okay, so habe ich das auch schon wahrgenommen, dass das sozusagen auch die Motivation ist, aber es ist ja trotzdem ganz putzig. Bleiben wir noch mal so ein bisschen bei Fernsehkritik TV als Format. Das ist ja eigentlich ein, ja, also auf mich macht das so den Eindruck, als ob es auch ein sehr höherer getragenes Format ist. Übrigens auch wie Chaosradio Express. Das heißt, was ich damit meine ist, und das kannst du jetzt bestätigen oder nein sagen, aber das ist so mein Eindruck, dass sehr viel der Motivation, das zu tun aus dem Feedback herauskommt und auch sehr viel Beiträge auch da. Tatsächlich gibt es ja auch diese Gastbeiträge, also dass sozusagen auch sehr viel kontributiert wird, bis hin zu einer Kollaboration. Sehe ich das richtig oder ist das?
Nein, das ist vollkommen richtig. Also ich bekomme ja auch viele Hinweise von den Leuten. Gestern Abend lief das wieder im Fernsehen, hast du das gesehen oder so weiter. Ich habe ja auch schon konkrete Fälle beurteilt oder gebracht, wo Leute eben mehr oder minder Opfer von Fernsehen geworden sind. Also der eine Typ, der bei das Model und der Freak da mitgemacht hat als Kandidat oder diese Familie, die Frauentausch dabei war, wo die ganze Wohnung verdreckt wurde von dem Fernsehteam, damit die Familie asozialer wirkt und so weiter. Das sind teilweise, melden sich solche Leute bei mir sogar und sagen, dann bring noch mal was darüber. Und ich hab auch schon leider, ich hab Fälle auch gehabt, wo ich gesagt habe, ihr müsst aber wissen, ihr habt einen Knebelvertrag unterschrieben, ihr dürft eigentlich darüber nichts erzählen. Und einige haben dann halt einen Rückzieher gemacht. Also eine Familie zum Beispiel, die von der Supernanny verarscht wurde, auf Deutsch gesagt, weil die Kinder haben Regieanweisungen bekommen. Ja, genau. Und die Kinder wurden halt als durchgeknallte kleine Monster dargestellt. Und das waren aber in Wahrheit Regieanweisungen von RTL. Hier tritt man dann eine Mutter und so weiter und macht mal ein bisschen Randale und so. Aber diese Familie hat leider da zu große Angst gehabt. Die waren sogar so naiv, bei RTL nachzufragen, ob sie das dürfen. Ich meine, das ist natürlich klar, dass RTL sagt, wenn ihr das macht, müsst ihr eine Geldstrafe bezahlen. Das wäre natürlich auch eine schöne Geschichte gewesen, aber muss ich natürlich akzeptieren. Insofern, wenn man dieses Magazin mit Zeit lang macht und da muss man halt auch einen langen Atem haben, hat man halt irgendwann auch die Position ein Stück weit, dass man die Leute sich bei einem auch melden. Weil man so eine Art glaubwürdiger Anwalt wird von Leuten, die Ärger mit dem Fernsehen hatten. Und das hoffe ich auch, wird sich noch ein bisschen weiter rumsprechen, weil dadurch man natürlich auch hochinteressante Geschichten bekommt.
Ja, Ärger mit dem Fernsehen, hast ja auch selber eine ganze Menge gehabt, so wie es den Eindruck macht. Also haben wir jetzt noch nicht so drüber geredet über diese Chorinnen-Geschichten, aber du bist ja auch selber verklagt worden. Und das ist auch, glaube ich, alles noch anhängig und läuft gerade noch.
Na, verklagt bin ich nicht worden. Ich habe ein-zweilige Verfügungen bekommen. Und da geht es jetzt um Gerichte darum, ob die nun zulässig sind oder nicht. Also Klage habe ich bisher noch nicht bekommen zum Glück.
Okay, aber vielleicht noch kurz noch bei der Sendung, bevor wir darauf gehen. Also so dieses Format an sich ist ja ein sehr modernes Format. Also ich sage das jetzt einfach mal. Für mich ist das irgendwie modern. Man sendet primär ins Netz. Es gibt ja keine Frequenz oder so. Bisher hast du ja keinen Kanal im dritten Programm oder so. Oder gar bei irgendeinem privaten. Oder machst du das irgendwie selber. Was bedeutet das dann für deine Reichweite? Hast du das Gefühl, dass du durch dieses Senden im Internet irgendwie in deiner Reichweite beschränkt bist? Oder ist es eher ein Vorteil?
Naja, ich sag mal, wenn das jetzt bei einem großen deutschen Fernsehsender laufen würde, würde ich natürlich mehr Leute erreichen. Das ist ja klar. Auf der anderen Seite gab es schon mal Leute, die zu mir gesagt haben, ja, mach das doch mal hier in Hamburg. Da gibt es Tide. Das ist so eine Art Bürgerfernsehen. Früher war das der offene Kanal Hamburg. Also da bin ich mit meinen Nutzerzahlen im Internet schon weit drüber hinweg, also mit den Zuschauerzahlen. Ich würde noch einen Bruchteil erreichen, wenn ich das über diesen Fernsehsender Tide machen würde. Also insofern vermischt es sich schon mittlerweile ein bisschen. Nö, ich bin im Internet ja viel freier. Ich kann machen, was ich will. Ich bin an keine bestimmte Sendetlänge gebunden. Je nachdem, wie es anfällt, welche Themen ich habe, kann ich es eine dreiviertel Stunde machen oder eine halbe Stunde machen. Ich kann das alles selber viel besser steuern. Ich bin niemandem Rechenschaft schuldig. Insofern ist das, das ist ja das Fernsehen von morgen. Ich meine, Internet und Fernsehen wird sich im Laufe der Jahre immer weiter vermischen. Also die Mediathek wird, denke ich, in ein paar Jahren das normale Fernsehen sein. Insofern sind wir doch eigentlich nur eher Pioniere, wenn wir da jetzt schon das Konsequenz so weiterführen.
Kann schon sein. Kann schon sein. Ja, jetzt nochmal zu dem Ärger. Also wo fangen wir denn da an? Also du hast ja, das ist ja echt ein weites Feld. Also du hast es ja schon eingangs mit deiner Geschichte, da mit Springer und diesen Methoden gemacht. Es gibt Segmente, also ich sage jetzt gar nicht mal das Fernsehen, aber es gibt einfach Segmente in der Fernsehproduktionslandschaft, da geht es doch mit sehr spitzen Ellenbogen zu. Was jetzt immer eine besondere Rolle spielt, auch bei ihrem Programm, sind diese Call-In-Geschichten. Ich weiß gar nicht, wer hat denn eigentlich damit angefangen? Ich meine, als das neue Live geboren wurde, war das ja noch nicht neu, also da gab es das ja schon vorher. Aber das ist meines Wissens der erste Sender, der sich um Wesentlichen eigentlich nur damit beschäftigt hat. Was ist so deine Kenntnis und was hast du so mitbekommen aus dieser Welt?
Ja, also das ganze Unheil ging ja im Grunde genommen los, dass die Deutsche Telekom irgendwann in der Lage war, Telefonnummern zu steuern nach Telefongebühren. Also früher gab es nur das Ortsgespräch und das Ferngespräch, so als wir Kinder waren. Und heute ist es halt so, man kann halt mit solchen Telefonnummern eben auch Geld verdienen, Service-Hotlines etc. und die sogenannten Mehrwertdienste. Und daraus hat das Fernsehen irgendwann ein Geschäft gemacht. Und diese Gewinnspiele über Telefon-Hotlines, die waren offenbar so zunächst erfolgreich, weil die Leute natürlich alle naiv waren und geglaubt haben, sie können tatsächlich eine reale Chance haben, wenn sie da anrufen, dass man eben dann ganzen Sender draus gemacht hat. Und Neuen Live war auch über einen lange Zeitraum äußerst profitabel. Aber mittlerweile ist die Aufklärung schon so weit fortgeschritten, dass Neuen Live ja zum Glück schon ein Sorgenkind von ProSieben Sat.1 geworden ist. Die versuchen ja schon, das Ding loszuwerden langsam. Und es schadet ja auch dem Ruf, eher dieses Fernsehkonzern inzwischen schon. Neuen Live ist ja als Begriff, steht das eigentlich für ein negatives, böses, schlechtes Fernsehen. Also da ist die Aufklärung schon vorangegangen. Was diesen Ärger angeht, den ich da habe, das ist ja noch eine Stufe schlimmer oder heftiger. Da geht es ja um das, was in Österreich und Schweiz passiert ist. Denn dort, und das ist eben das, was wir versucht haben darzustellen in einem Filmbericht, ist es ja so, dass offensichtlich, und man muss es eben sagen, offensichtlich, nach unserer Erkenntnis, so ist, dass dort sogar mit gefakten Anrufen gearbeitet wird. Das heißt, dem Zuschauer wird vorgegaukelt, da kommen dauernd Leute durch. Und das ist ganz einfach, da anzurufen. Du siehst, da werden dauernd Leute durchgestellt. Und diese Leute, die da durchgestellt werden, haben aber komischerweise immer dieselbe Stimme.
Vielleicht sollen wir den Fernsehabsehenden Menschen unter unseren Zuhörern auch noch kurz klarmachen, was Call-In eigentlich konkret bedeutet. Also es sind immer irgendwelche Show-Schnipsel, wie lange läuft sowas? Die sind teilweise eine Stunde lang am Senden.
Ja, also Leif hatte schon mal 13 Stunden lang einen Rätsel am Laufen. Ja, es sind halt Rätsel oftmals.
So Fernseh-Kreuzwort-Rätsel mäßig.
Kreuzwort-Rätsel oder nennen sie... Also es gibt zwei Versionen. Das eine ist, da ist eine Flip-Shart, da sind ganz viele verdeckte Begriffe. Und dann nennen sie Tiere mit S oder so. Und dann rufen sich Leute an, die meinen Schwein oder Schaf oder so. Und am Ende ist es dann so ein Tier wie der Stirnlappen-Basilisk. Das sind die Spiele, wo andauernd Leute durchgestellt werden, weil neuen Life ganz genau weiß, auf unsere Begriffe, die wir da suchen, kommt sowieso keine Socke. Das andere ist, da sind die Lösungen relativ einfach. Da kommt im Grunde jeder drauf. Da ist es dann aber so, dass lange, lange Zeit niemand durchgestellt wird. Also die Leute versuchen alle anzurufen, weil sie alle die Lösung wissen.
Und die hängen dann alle in der Warteschleife nur Zahlen.
Genau, sie kriegen alle eine Bandansage, guten Tag, leider hat es nicht geklappt, aber der Anruf kostete 50 Cent, versuchen sie es gleich nochmal. So, das war es dann.
Wobei da jetzt gerade eine gesetzliche Änderung, glaube ich, auf den Weg gebracht worden ist, dass Warteschleifen nichts mehr kosten dürfen.
Es ist da keine Warteschleife in dem Sinne.
Ja, die werden wahrscheinlich schon einen Weg drumrum finden.
Es ist eine Bandansage und die ist dann auch noch zehn Sekunden beendet. Also man kriegt nur die Mitteilung, sie haben jetzt Geld abgedrückt, auf Wiedersehen. Vielen Dank für ihre Beiträge. Ja, genau, richtig. Ja, diese langen Durchstellpausen, die sind auch verboten worden. Also das 13 Stunden, das dürfte jetzt neuen Live auch nicht mehr machen. Wobei das jetzt so ein bisschen in der Schwebe ist.
Wie hingen da Leute 13 Stunden in der Leitung oder was?
Nee, die haben einfach 13 Stunden lang dieses Rätsel einfach gespielt, ohne jemanden ins Studio einen Anrufer durchzulassen. Rufen sie jetzt an, gleich, jetzt, der Countdown läuft bereits. Und jetzt immer wieder ein neuer Countdown.
Alle haben sich gewundert, warum ruft denn da keiner an, das ist doch so einfach.
Ja genau, genau, 13 Stunden lang.
Das ist schon ganz schön abgründig.
Das ist sehr abgründig, ja, das stimmt. Aber es hat lange Zeit funktioniert und ja, im Grunde genommen reicht es auch eigentlich nicht, wenn man tatsächlich irgendwann mal soweit ist, dass diese Art von Fernsehen dann auch mal überholt ist und abgeschafft wird. Man müsste im Grunde genommen auch die Macher dieser Sender noch zur Rechenschaft ziehen, finde ich. Aber es wird, glaube ich, sehr schwer. Die haben sich eine goldene Nase verdient.
Aber du hast das aufgegriffen, ich glaube, da gab es nicht so eine Webseite, callintv.de oder so, ähnlich?
Ja, de, dann war es nett. Jetzt gibt es hier demnächst eine neue. Das ist von dem Marc Döhler aus Berlin, genau. Der hat ja mit seinen Leuten, das ist so eine kleine, eingesporene Gemeinde, die sind richtig exzessiv und gucken das jeden Tag von morgens bis abends und protokollieren es, schneiden es mit und haben da unglaublich viele Dinge natürlich auch an den Tag gebracht. Weil dieses Call-in-Fernsehen läuft natürlich nach dem Prinzip, der normale Zuschauer, der mal zwölfzehn Minuten rein zappt und dann vielleicht sogar versucht, da anzurufen und merkt, ich komme nicht durch und nach zehn Minuten ist es immer noch nicht, der schaltet irgendwann gelangweilt weiter, der bleibt dann nicht stundenlang da vorhängen. Und das ist ja deren Prinzip, dass sie genau wissen, der normale Zuschauer, der kriegt davon nichts mit, mit weichem, welche Methoden da gearbeitet wird, das haben eben erst Leute wie Marc Döller und Co. an den Tag gebracht, weil die eben wirklich das protokolliert haben, analysiert haben, zusammengeschnitten haben auf die wesentlichen Momente dieser vielen Stunden Fernsehen, die da gezeigt werden. Ja und dadurch ist einem erst klarer geworden, mit welchen Methoden da gearbeitet wird.
Die haben aber dann auch ganz schön Gegenwind bekommen.
Also 9Live hat noch nie irgendwie geklagt oder sonst irgendwas.
Ich meinte jetzt die Leute von ColinTV.
Ja, richtig. Aber das ist eben auch wieder diese Firma aus Österreich. Also die ist vor allem...
Okay, dann erzähl mal, was es mit der auf sich hat.
Ja, also in Österreich und Schweiz gibt's halt ColinTV auch und dort ist es so, dass es unglaublich viele Ungereimtheiten gibt. Wie ich ja schon sagte, es gibt immer wieder die Anrufer, die dieselben Stimmen haben, aber komischerweise jedes Mal einen anderen Namen nennen. Hallo, hier ist Anneliese, Hallo, hier ist Gabi und so. Aber immer dieselbe Frauenstimme. Bei den Männern ist es genauso. Und ja, insofern muss man den Verdacht haben und das haben wir eben auch formuliert. Marc Döller hat einen 75-minütigen Film gemacht fürs Netz, einen Dokumentarfilm, wo er das alles schön analysiert hat und protokolliert hat, wo wir das eben auch aufgezeigt haben, wo auch irgendwie ein Umschlag mit Lösungen irgendwo abgelegt wurde, dann ist die Kamera kurz mal weg und dann ging die Kamera wieder hin, dann lag das QVR plötzlich anders als vorher, wo man auch den Verdacht haben muss, hat da jemand den Lösungsumschlag ausgetauscht und solche Dinge. Ja, und diese Firma da aus Österreich, aus Wien, die hat das gar nicht witzig gefunden und hat da wirklich einen juristischen Amoklauf gestartet, sowohl gegen mich, weil auf meiner Seite dieser Filmbericht eben auch abrufbar war, als auch gegen Marc Döhler, der eben Autor.
Was ging denn zum Wesentlichen um diesen Film?
Ja, also es ist etwas komplizierter, weil es gibt diese Firma in Österreich, es gibt immer noch eine Tochterfirma, von denen gegründet, die hat ihren Sitz in München. Während der Zeit, als dieser Filmbericht entstanden ist, war es nun so, dass diese Mutterfirma in Wien diese Verantwortlichkeit übertragen hat auf diese Tochterfirma. Dann haben wir in diesem Filmbericht auch diese Mutterfirma mehrmals genannt. Das wiederum war leider auch für den juristischen Aufhänger zu sagen, was wollen sie eigentlich von uns, wir haben damit gar nichts zu tun. Das ist diese Firma in München, wir sind nicht der Produzent. Also konnten die leider auf der Ebene gegen uns vorgehen, obwohl es im Grunde genommen juristischer Taschenspielertrick ist. Wir haben ja auch darlegen können, dass in deren Impressum nach wie vor der Name der Mutterfirma in Wien genannt wurde. Aber Gericht hat eben gesagt, nur ein Impressum heißt zwar, die sind vielleicht verantwortlich, die sind aber nicht unbedingt der Produzent. Das war die juristische Kleinkrämerei, auf der Ebene haben wir dann leider die Sache verloren, hier vom Landgericht Hamburg. Und dann gab es aber noch die zweite Ebene und die läuft noch, dass auch diese Firma in München, diese Tochterfirma, direkt geklagt hat oder eine einstweilige Verfügung versucht hat durchzusetzen. Da ging es ums Inhaltliche, weil da gesagt wurde, auch das was da behauptet würde, inhaltlich ist alles Quatsch, stimmt überhaupt nicht, wir betrügen hier niemanden, das ist alles ganz seriös und so. Und das läuft vom Oberlandesgericht München. Da haben wir aber teilweise recht bekommen. Wir haben vom Landgericht München sogar komplett recht bekommen. Da wurde die einstweilige Verfügung abgeschmettert. Also da gehen wir auch noch weiter, weil wir da einfach auch große Chancen sehen, dass wir da noch was erreichen können. Wohingegen diese Geschichte mit dieser Mutterfirma, mit dieser Namensnennung, da hat es keinen Zweck gehabt, das noch länger zu verfolgen.
Wenn du sagst wir, ist das im Wesentlichen nur du?
Nö, wir und mein Anwalt jetzt und natürlich auch Marc und sein Anwalt. Wir sind natürlich auch in Kommunikation miteinander.
Und dieser Film, der ist jetzt sozusagen nicht mehr verlinkt bei euch?
Nee, nee, den muss man natürlich mal...
Welchen Titel hatte er?
Er hieß anrufen und verlieren, in Anlehnung an die österreichische Sendung, die heißt anrufen und gewinnen. Es hat aber mittlerweile auch trotzdem schon natürlich positive Konsequenzen gehabt. Das Swiss Prison in der Schweiz gibt es nicht mehr, das ist abgesetzt worden und zwar von ein Tag auf den anderen, weil da hat auch die Staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt und in Österreich ist jetzt angekündigt worden, dass es zum Jahresende angeblich auch damit vorbei sein soll mit dieser Sendung. Und da haben wir sicherlich auch unseren Teil zu beigetragen. Also nicht nur wir, es gibt in der Schweiz ein wunderbares Fernsehmagazin, das heißt Kassensturz, das sehr investigativ auch über solche Dinge berichtet.
Im normalen Fernsehen oder auch im Netz?
Im Schweizer Fernsehen, im normalen Fernsehen. Würde ich mir auch in Deutschland wünschen, dass es so ein Magazin gäbe. Und die haben natürlich mehrmals auch wirklich knallhart darüber berichtet. Und das hat auch natürlich eine Menge dazu beigetragen, dass es in der Schweiz kein Colin-TV mehr gibt. Das ist mittlerweile, das Fernsehen ist komplett davon befreit, kann man sagen. Colin-freie Zone.
Wie kritikfähig ist denn das Fernsehen?
Wenig. Also das Fernsehen, also vor allem das öffentlich-rechtliche Fernsehen, müsste sich eigentlich auch mit sich selber viel mehr beschäftigen. Ich finde doch, das gehört zur Aufgabe des öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehens. Sich selbst hinterfragen, die gesellschaftliche Relevanz hinterfragen, welche Aufgabe haben wir, welche Verantwortung haben wir den Zuschauern gegenüber. Solche Hinterfragungen gibt es nicht mehr und die privaten natürlich sowieso nicht. Die privaten sind Unternehmen, die sind gewinnorientiert, die senden das, was Quote bringt oder was Gewinn bringt. Da müsste von staatlicher Seite, müsste es da viel stärkere Vorgaben geben, also von selber, wenn die Sendung das nicht mehr, äh die Sender, was sie machen.
Vorgaben zum Beispiel dafür, dass man überhaupt die Sendelizenz, also dass man Frequenzen erhält zum Beispiel.
Ja, ich finde, ähm.
Aber ich meine, es gibt ja Vorgaben, so ist ja nicht, ne?
Die gibt es, aber sie sind leider nur oft auf dem Papier, ne? Und es gibt dann von den Landesmedienanstalten, das sind ja alles zahnlose Tiger, die sprechen dann irgendwelche Drohungen aus und Appelle aus, aber dass da wirklich mal Konsequenzen gezogen werden, auch wenn es, selbst wenn mal eine Geldstrafe verhängt wird, also ich meine, wenn der Sender irgendwie über Werbeeinnahmen das zehnfache eingenommen hat, ist ihm die Geldstrafe auch egal. Da würde ich mir viel mehr Härte wünschen.
Aber wenn man jetzt mal so das Fernsehen so als, also wenn ich beim Fernsehen wäre, dann wäre mir das ja überhaupt nicht recht, dass es so viel schwarze Schafe gibt, dass sozusagen das gesamte Genre damit so sehr in Mitleidenschaft gezogen wird.
Sehe ich auch so, ja. Aber so denken offenbar Fernsehmanager nicht. Zumindest diejenigen, die jetzt momentan da am Ruder sind, stelle ich zumindest nicht fest. Weil es gibt natürlich auch viel Druck von der Werbeindustrie. Es gibt auch eine Lobby in der Politik und so weiter. Ich weiß ja auch nicht, man kann natürlich jetzt die größten Verschwörungstheorien da entwickeln und sagen, die Politik hat Interesse daran, dass das Volk nur dummes Fernsehen zu sehen bekommt, um auch das Volk langfristig gefügiger zu machen. Weil ein Volk, das selbstbewusst ist und zu viel denkt, ist natürlich auch der Politik gegenüber zu unbequem. Ist jetzt Verschwörungstheorie, aber soweit könnte man ja sogar gehen. Insofern ist gut gedacht, aber ich glaube, mit der Position kämpfst du nicht durch beim Fernsehen.
Aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass es keine kritischen Stimmen gäbe. Ich meine, Kassensturz, das ist jetzt ein Beispiel. Kennst du andere Beispiele, vielleicht auch in Deutschland?
Ja, natürlich ist SAP ein ganz gutes Magazin im NDR. Das gibt es Mittwoch abends spät. Wobei, ja, es ist auch nicht immer... Also, die kritisieren zwar auch das Fernsehen, auch andere öffentlich-rechtliche Sender, aber der NDR zum Beispiel, der das produziert, kommt eigentlich immer recht gut weg beim Magazin. Und vor kurzem gab es dann auch einen Bericht über die GEZ, den ich also auch so ärgerlich fand, dass ich sogar darüber einen Beitrag gemacht habe, weil jetzt irgendwie nur zu sagen, die GEZ gibt sich jetzt ein positives Image mittels einer neuen Werbekampagne. Heißt ja nicht, dass die GEZ besser geworden wäre. Die arbeitet natürlich nach wie vor genauso wie vorher. Ach so, hast recht, das war ja die eigentliche Frage. Also was investigative Auseinandersetzungen mit Medien angeht, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, fällt mir nichts weiter ein. Wüsste ich nicht. Warst du ein Beispiel?
Ich weiß nicht. Es gibt so ein paar Satiresendungen, die irgendwie einen erfrischenden Blick auf die Gesellschaft als solche, wo überhaupt kritische Berichterstattung von überhaupt Dingen Platz finden.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, meinen Magazin nenne ich ja auch satirisch kritisch, aber die Satire hat halt auch irgendwann ihre Grenzen. Also es gibt manche Dinge, da kann man gar nicht mehr drüber lachen. Ne, genau. Also als ich angefangen habe, habe ich auch gedacht, ah jetzt mache ich mal hier was so ein bisschen. Ich spotte übers Fernsehen und mache mich ein bisschen lustig drüber. So war ja das eigentlich die eigentliche Idee vor allem. Aber auch durch die Erfahrung, die ich ja vorher schon gemacht hatte, war mir natürlich sehr schnell klar, es gibt Themen, da kann man nur ernsthaft drüber berichten und muss auch knallhart die Dinge beim Namen nennen. Das ist nicht mehr zum Lachen. Das ist wirklich ernst. Also ja, ich würde es mir wünschen. Also es wäre auch eigentlich, wie gesagt, Aufgabe der Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, so was im Programm zu haben. Eine Reflektion des Mediums Fernsehens, kritisch, investigativ, journalistisch.
Wie kritisch ist denn diese Kassensturz denn noch?
Na Kassensturz, muss man wissen, ist ein Magazin, das sich auch befasst mit, also mindestens Verbrauchermagazinen. Es geht dabei auch um, was ich betrug bei Kaffeepfarten oder Telefon-Hotlines. Also auch jetzt nicht unbedingt nur Fernsehen. Aber dieses war halt auch ein Thema in dieser Sendung.
Und Österreich?
Das österreichische Fernsehen ist noch viel schlimmer als das deutsche. Also wenn man sich da ORF anschaut, ORF nudelt im Grunde genommen die ganzen von morgens bis abends die ganzen Serien ab, die bei uns pro sieben so sendet. Also Desperate Housewives und uns alles. Also das öffentlich-rechtliche Fernsehen in Österreich ist völlig unten durch, auch quotenmäßig. Die Leute haben sich so mit Grausen davon abgewandt. Das ist ganz schlimm. Also österreichisches Fernsehen ist ganz schlimm.
Aber wo gehen die Leute denn hin, wenn sie nicht mehr fernsehen? Also ich meine, gucken sie dann kein Fernsehen mehr? Ich habe das Gefühl, dieser Hunger nach Fernsehen, der ist nicht stillbar und die Leute nehmen dann am Ende dann doch wieder alles, was sie kriegen. Also der Hunger ist vielleicht stillbar, aber nur dadurch, dass man dann eben doch guckt, egal was kommt. Es enthält zwar keine Nahrungsmittel, aber ich esse es trotzdem.
Ja, ist doch eine Generationenfrage. Also die ältere Generation ist gewohnt, dass sie abends den Fernseher anmacht, sehe ich bei meinen Eltern auch. Und die gucken sich auch das wahrscheinlich an.
Und eine neue Generation siehst du da schon am Horizont?
Ja, sicher, also natürlich, die neue Generation schaut Fernsehen jetzt ja auch schon oft über den Computerbildschirm, übers Internet, über Mediatheken oder hat Fernsehempfang über den Computermonitor. Das heißt, man hat auf dem kleinen Fenster oben in der Ecke das Fernsehen laufen, chattet nebenbei. Also ist ja alles viel interaktiver als früher. Und dieses mit der Familie, sich vor den Fernseher zu setzen, und wir gucken jetzt alle zwei Stunden lang Fernsehen, das ist mittlerweile wohl eher die Ausnahme.
Also ist es individueller geworden? Aber trotzdem gibt es ja immer noch so dieses Massenphänomen. Irgendwie auch, glaube ich, so einen kollektiven Wunsch, dass man dann doch wieder zurück zu Wim Tölke, ja, 80 Prozent aller Leute nehmen jetzt sozusagen dasselbe wahr. Das drückt sich jetzt bloß nicht mehr so in regelmäßigen Sendungen aus, sondern man hat halt dann so Sachen wie jetzt gerade die Fußball-WM, na gut, die läuft sowieso außer Konkurrenz, aber jetzt gerade der Wahn um die Euro-Visions-Contest da mit der Lena-Maja-Landrut, die ja dann sozusagen, also so hat sich mir das dargestellt, dann waren sie alle so glücklich, dass sie sich endlich mal wieder auf was geeinigt haben, was man jetzt irgendwie gemeinsam kollektiv befeiert und irgendwie feiert man sich dabei ja auch gegenseitig. Das ist eigentlich auch genauso wie beim Fußball jetzt auch. Also es ist eigentlich schon auch eine Freude da, die eigentlich ihren Kanal sucht. Und sie sucht quasi ihren Kanal auch im Fernsehen. Aber das Fernsehen, bedient das wohl nicht immer so?
Ja, zu wenig zumindest.
Wusstest du das überhaupt?
Ach naja, also ich meine jeder Sender wird sich doch glücklich schätzen, wenn er regelmäßig solche Quoten wie zur Fußball-WM hätte. Aber es ist natürlich schwer. Ich meine, das ist ja heutzutage bei den vielen Sendern so. Jeder Sender versucht mit irgendwelchen Casting-Shows und so diesen Hype auszulösen, aber den wenigsten gelingt es natürlich.
Ja.
Soll ich weitersprechen oder?
Ja, ja. Ich wundere mich nur gerade, warum das hier irgendwie klingelt. Es ist eigentlich ausgeschaltet, es soll nicht klingeln. Ich wundere mich, warum ich überhaupt was höre. Ja, aber sprich einfach, lass dich einfach nicht ablenken.
Ich fang nochmal von vorne an bei der Antwort. Ich denke, jeder Sender würde sich natürlich wünschen, eine Quote zu haben, wie bei der Fußball-WM, das ist ja klar. Aber es ist natürlich heutzutage schwierig, so einen Hype auszulösen, weil es so viele Sender gibt. Und jeder Sender versucht irgendwie, das hinzukriegen. RTL versucht es mit DSDS, was auch nach wie vor bei der bestimmten Zielgruppe auch funktioniert. ProSieben versucht es mit Popstars.
Also DSDS Deutschland sucht den so was. Ich muss was immer übersetzen, muss immer davon ausgehen. Das hat vielleicht jeder mitbekommen. Wenn man so im Internet steckt.
Die erfolgreichste deutsche Castingshow, kann man sagen. Die quotenmäßig sehr erfolgreich ist. Man kann dazu auch viel sagen. ProSieben versucht es mit Popstars und so. Ja, bei dem Eurovision Song Contest war es natürlich jetzt so, dass es ein internationaler Wettbewerb ist. Das heißt, wir alle stehen hinter einer Person, weil die unser Land als solches vertritt. Bei den Superstars gibt es dann Menowin oder Merzad. Diejenigen, die vielleicht für jemand anders waren, der lex ausgeschieden war, die haben gar nicht mehr zugeschaut. Hier hatten wir alle miteinander was, wo wir hinter gestanden haben. Im Fußball ist es ja genauso. Das sind aber internationale Wettbewerbe, da gibt es ja nicht so viele. Es wäre schön, wenn es das noch mehr gäbe. Das schweißt die Leute in dem Moment auch zusammen. Die Quote von diesem Eurovision Song Contest war ja auch unglaublich. 14 Millionen oder so hatte das, glaube ich. Das war eine tolle Quote.
Das ist schon viel. Aber wie viele Leute gucken in der Web noch Fernsehen?
Wie viele Leute?
Ja, ich lebe ja so in Kreisen, da hat man manchmal das Gefühl, es guckt eigentlich gar keiner mehr. Man wundert sich, warum die Zeitungen immer noch darüber berichten.
Man muss ja einfach wissen, es gibt ja die geburtenstarken Jahrgänge, die sind ja die Jahrgänge ab meiner Generation, also ab Anfang der 70er Jahre geboren und älter. Und die sind natürlich auch mehr in dieser Gewohnheit noch drin, dass sie abends Fernsehen gucken. Und deswegen gucken auch noch viele Leute im Fernsehen.
Aber die werden halt immer älter.
Ja, und deswegen setzen ja auch ARD und ZDF mit ihren ganzen Heimat-Schmonzetten und ihren ganzen Sendungen, ihren ganzen seichten Programmen darauf, dass sie nach wie vor sehr stark Quoten über diese Zuschauerschaft sich holen, um auf dem Papier eine gute Quote zu haben. Also wenn ZDF eine stolze Pressemitteilung verschickt, ja, Rosamunde Pilcher hatte wieder 7 Millionen Zuschauer gestern Abend. Und man sich dann anschauen würde, wie war es denn bei den Zuschauern von 14 bis 39 oder bis 49, dann würde man schnell feststellen, das war ein ganz geringer Marktanteil, der erreicht wurde. Das hat sich so gut wie keiner angeschaut. Das ist halt, dass es alte Leute fernsehen. Aber es funktioniert noch, weil diese Generation noch lebendig ist natürlich und sehr stark aus Gewohnheit Fernsehen einfach nutzt. Aber das wird mit der Zeit sich natürlich stark verändern.
Ja, aber jetzt hast du doch eine ganze Menge Feedback von genau dieser jungen Generation, die quasi dein Programm schaut und sich damit ja auch kritisch auseinandersetzt, wenn sie es noch nicht vorher getan haben, spätestens nachdem sie dann sozusagen da in deiner Community auch teilnehmen. Was ist denn dein Eindruck, was für einen Stellenwert Fernsehen da überhaupt noch hat? Ist das noch genauso wichtig oder ist das irgendwie... Ist das so die Suche nach diesem identitätsstiftenden, gemeinden Ding, so dieser, meine tägliche Lena, mir heute?
Nö, glaube ich nicht. Es gibt halt amerikanische Serien, die halt sehr beliebt sind. Was weiß ich, die Simpsons und South Park und die ganzen 24 und Lost und so weiter. Und da gibt es natürlich zum einen die wirklichen Freaks unter den Jugendlichen. Das sind die, die wenig Fernsehen gucken. Die besorgen sich schon früh aus dem Netz, in der amerikanischen Original-Fassung irgendwo gezogen und bevor es lange im deutschen Fernsehen läuft. Oder kaufen sich die DVD oder irgendwas. Aber es gibt natürlich eine andere große Gruppe von Jugendlichen, die haben diese Kompetenz gar nicht, sich das irgendwo zu besorgen. Oder denen ist es auch vielleicht zu anstrengend, sich das in Original-Englisch anzuschauen. Die warten lieber darauf, dass es in Deutsch kommt. Und das sind natürlich diejenigen, die auch den Fernsehen gucken. Und die dann dies auch nutzen nach wie vor. Also es gibt eben nicht die Jugendlichen, es gibt da sehr unterschiedliche Schichten oder sehr unterschiedliche Gruppen.
Aber wenn du jetzt sagst, die ganzen Fernsehsender, die kümmern sich jetzt im Wesentlichen nur noch um die alten Geburten, ja an Geburtsstangen.
Ja, die öffentlich-rechtlichen würde man ja. Die privaten natürlich nicht. Weil bei denen ist es ja wiederum eine andere Ansatzweise, weil die bekommen von der Werbeindustrie ja vorgegeben, wir müssen unsere Zielgruppe bedienen. Das sind die 14- bis 49-Jährigen, obwohl das eigentlich eine völlig wirre Zahl ist, die ist irgendwann von jemandem erfunden worden. Und darauf setzt die Industrie, die Werbeindustrie nach wie vor offensichtlich. Und deswegen sind die Sender, die Privatsender auch so bestrebt, immer diese Gruppe zu erreichen. Und da es sehr schwer ist, diese Gruppe eben noch quotenmäßig stark an sich zu binden, weil viele von denen gucken halt kein Fernsehen mehr, ist es mittlerweile so, dass das Fernsehen auch nicht mehr viel kosten darf. Es wird immer billiger, weil man kann mit Überwärmeeinnahmen immer weniger verdienen. Und deswegen ist das private Fernsehen momentan eigentlich auf dem absteigenden Ast weiter, sowohl was das Niveau angeht, als auch was die Überlebensfähigkeit angeht. Also, weil man fokussiert sich nach wie vor auf eine Zielgruppe, die eigentlich gar nicht mehr so fernsehinteressiert ist zu einem Teil. Und deswegen sind die Quoten halt auch so schlecht.
Hängt aber so ein bisschen davon ab, wer man fragt. Auf der einen Seite gibt es so diese Fernsehwirt, wird es immer geben und Fernsehen wird immer das Leitmedium sein. Und wenn ich dich jetzt so höre, dann könnte man auch sagen, ok, könnte es vielleicht tatsächlich so was wie eine so dramatisch sinkende Fernsehbeteiligung geben, dass das irgendwann so diese Rolle des Leitmediums gar nicht mehr hat.
Ja, also wie gesagt, in ein paar Jahren wird sich Fernsehen mit Internet viel mehr vermischt haben. Und dann gibt es so dieses passive Gucken, das gibt es in dem Sinne wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr. Natürlich, wenn man sich ein bisschen...
Das ist sicher, vielleicht ist das wieder der Traum von dem interaktiven Fernsehen, das kommt dann gar nicht.
Ja, doch, doch, das kommt. Also, lang, mittelfristig werden Sender wie RTL und ProSieben und so weiter werden nur überleben können, wenn sie irgendwann so weit sind, dass sie auch für gewisse Programmeinhalte Geld nehmen. Das geht nicht mehr über Werbung zu finanzieren. Wenn ProSieben oder Sat.1 eine große Show produziert oder eine richtige Fernsehserie produziert, jetzt wie zum Beispiel Sat.1 mit Der letzte Bulle und Danny Lewinsky, das waren mal wieder richtige Fernsehserien beim Privatfernseh, das gab es ja lange nicht. Die kosten halt sehr viel Geld. Das kann man über Werbeeinnahmen allein nicht mehr finanzieren. Man kann es versuchen, indem man es auf DVD rausbringt hinterher und über die DVD noch über den Verkaufserlös was einnimmt. Das hat zum Beispiel bei Stromberg gut funktioniert, weil Stromberg einfach so ein Kultpotenzial hat, dass die Leute unglaublich viele DVD gekauft haben hinterher.
Stromberg ist diese deutsche Art Option von The Office.
Von The Office und die DVD kam ja bereits raus mit Ausstrahlung der allerersten Folge im Fernsehen. Man konnte sich alle Folgen bereits auf DVD kaufen, bevor sie überhaupt bei ProSieben gelaufen sind. Das ist ja schon mal ein Zeichen dafür. Fernsehen wird immer mehr zum Nebenbei-Medium, auch für die Wirtschaft, für die Medienwirtschaft. Man will schon auf ganz anderen Wegen das Geld verdienen. Und da werden die Privatsender hinkommen müssen, weil die Werbeindustrie guckt sich ja auch natürlich um und wirbt mittlerweile auch lieber im Internet. Weil Fernsehwerbung ist halt auch sehr teuer. Man weiß nicht genau, wem erreicht man da jetzt eigentlich genau. Wenn ich im Internet Werbung schalte, weiß ich ganz genau. Ich zahle pro Klick und pro View, zahle ich meine zwei, drei Cent. Und dann weiß ich, da hat jemand noch diese Werbung angeklickt in dem Moment. Das heißt, ich kann ja viel spezieller werben und bezahle dann auch entsprechend dem Werbeerfolg, den ich damit hatte. Und da wird sich das Fernsehen auch was überlegen müssen, wenn es auf diese Art und Weise weiter auf dem Werbesegment erfolgreich sein will. Irgendwann wird es auch sicherlich soweit sein, dass die Einschaltquoten nicht jetzt am kommenden Morgen feststehen, sondern schon während einer Sendung ermittelt werden. Und schon währenddessen vielleicht ein Sender sagen kann, pass mal auf, diese Show hier, die hat unglaublich tolle Einschaltquoten, wollt ihr jetzt noch schnell einen Werbespot schalten zum Sonderpreis oder so. So wird das alles sich entwickeln. Und ja, da wird das Fernsehen hinkommen. Also das wird interaktiver von Seiten der Zuschauer und auch von Seiten der Macher. Aber wo das genau hinführt, weiß ich nicht.
Du hast gesagt bezahlte Inhalte. Ich meine, das Modell gibt es ja auch schon länger mit Premiere, jetzt Sky. So ein großer Erfolg war das ja in Deutschland nicht unbedingt. Oder war es das? Sehe ich das falsch?
Also im Sportbereich ist es ja durchaus ein Erfolg. Also Bundesliga live gucken, das wird sehr stark genutzt, soweit ich höre.
Aber auch genug, um die Kosten wieder reinzuspielen.
Also ich habe jetzt nicht die aktuellen Sky-Zahlen, weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber sie scheinen zumindest schon auf einem ganz guten Weg zu sein. Weil sie waren natürlich schlau genug. Für Premiere hat es ja früher so gemacht, du kannst den Sportteil nur empfangen, wenn du auch das ganze andere Paket mitnimmst. Wenn du dir auch die ganzen Spielfilmkanäle mit abonnierst. Und das war natürlich dumm, weil es gibt Sportfans, die interessieren sich für Filme nicht. Und denen waren es einfach zu teuer. Und jetzt ist es mittlerweile ja schon so, man kann eben für, was weiß ich, was kostet das? 15, 20 Euro oder sowas im Monat, glaube ich, nur diese Sport live Bundesliga-Berichterstattung abonnieren. Dass man nur das sich anguckt. Und ich sag mal, wenn ich für jede Woche, wenn ich für eine Eintrittskarte auch meine 10, 20 Euro jede Woche bezahlen würde und so kann ich bequem zu Hause gucken in HD-Qualität, wenn ich einen tollen Fernseher habe, ist es nicht zu teuer, finde ich. Das ist durchaus bezahlbar. Und wer wirklich ein Fußballfan ist und jede Woche seinen Verein live sehen will, für den wird da auch einiges geboten.
Das heißt, am Ende kommen wir eigentlich weg von diesem Mischprogramm hin zu einem Spaten-Spezialisierungs-Ding, ähnlich wie im Netz eigentlich auch, wo ja auch die Spezialisierung ganz vormals...
Ja, und wir kriegen vor allem ein Zwei-Klassen-Fernsehen noch stärker, weil es gibt natürlich viele Menschen, die haben nicht viel Geld, die können sich das natürlich nicht leisten, Geld zu bezahlen für Fernsehen. Die bleiben dann eben am Ende tatsächlich hängen auf diesen ganzen billig produzierten Daily Soaps, die man natürlich auch locker werbefinanziert bringen kann. Das wird auch keiner Geld für bezahlen. Also keiner schaut sich mitten im Leben an gegen Geld. Das ist nur Fernsehen, dass man mit ein paar Werbespots eben refinanzieren kann. Das kostet nicht viel Geld.
Mit dem Leben ist so eine...
Doku-Soap, gescriptet. Also man holt sich irgendwelche Leihendarsteller heran und lässt die mal ein bisschen die Sau rauslassen. Und das läuft nachmittags bei RTL.
Das sind so die Sachen, wo man so gleich die Hand auf dem Gesicht hat, wenn man da mal zufällig einschaltet.
Es ist Leihenspiel-Fernsehen, so kann man es immer übersetzen. Es ist ja immer schön, wie diese Begriffe immer... Gescriptete Doku-Soap, klingt ja super. Das ist Leihenspiel-Fernsehen. Und die Leute kriegen 100 Euro und einen warmen Händedruck oder was?
Gut, jetzt sind wir ja im Prinzip wieder bei den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, die ja genau diesen Auftrag eigentlich haben, nämlich ein Programm anzubieten für alle. Ja, mit Bildung, mit Kultur, mit Bereicherung, was weiß ich, mit Informationen, mit Nachrichten. Da sind sie ja immer ganz stolz darauf, dass sie ja angeblich da so nachhaltig informieren und überhaupt. Und ich meine, wenn man sich jetzt die Nachrichtensendung bei den Privaten anschaut, muss ich sagen, dagegen strahlt ja die Tagesschau wirklich in geleisendem Licht. Was nicht bedeutet, dass wenn ich jetzt nur von Tagesschaukonsum meinen Nachrichtenbedarf stillen würde, ich dann im selben Licht strahlen würde. Den Eindruck, den hat man nicht so. Jetzt haben wir ja anfangs schon, hast du schon erwähnt, dafür zahle ich nicht, so quasi der Appell mit ja, gerne Gebühren, aber ich möchte hier auch eine Qualitätskritik mit einbringen, so habe ich dich verstanden. Jetzt haben wir auch gerade vor kurzem die Entscheidung gehabt, dass das GEZ-Modell, so wie es heute existiert, so nicht fortgeführt wird, sondern es wird halt nicht mehr derjenige, der jetzt ein Empfangsgerät hat und dann auch noch für jedes einzelne Empfangsgerät in irgendeiner Form zur Kasse gebracht, sondern es gibt tatsächlich, lange diskutiert, endlich umgesetzt, eine Umlage, dass jeder Haushalt, und das schließt natürlich auch Haushalte ein, die kein Fernsehen haben, zahlt.
Also positiv daran finde ich, dass man zumindest diese schreckliche GEZ-Schnüffelei damit abschafft. Denn die GEZ wendet ja teilweise Methoden an, die fast an die gute alte Stasi erinnern, möchte ich mal so sagen. Da sitzen solche GEZ-Fan dahinter irgendwelchen Hecken und beobachten, ob irgendwo ein Fernseher flimmert, abends in irgendeiner Wohnung. Die verkleiden sich als Heizungsinstallateure. Nach dem Motto, können wir mal kurz in ihre Wohnung, wir müssen hier einen Heizungsrohr reparieren oder was weiß ich, ist unglaublich.
Das sind alles belegte Fälle?
Alles belegte Fälle, ja. Und wenn das abgeschafft wird, wenn das nicht mehr nötig sein wird, wenn diese ganze GEZ-Behörde am Ende vielleicht sogar dicht gemacht wird, wäre das ein positiver Aspekt. Ich finde auch Medienabgabe, so würde sie denn ja heißen, ist ja auch insofern vernünftig, weil auch wenn jemand kein Fernseher hat, keiner kann mir erzählen, dass er nicht trotzdem wenigstens Internetanschluss hat oder ein Handy hat. Und wenn jeder sozusagen einen kleinen Opulus in so einem gemeinsamen Topf zahlt, dafür, dass er ein Medien einfach nutzt, und es gibt ja auch im Internet diese Gratis-Mentalität, sage ich mal, es zahlt ja kaum jemand was fürs Internet, dann ist es natürlich auch in Ordnung. Das Problem ist jetzt Folgendes. Erstens, die öffentlich-rechtlichen Sachen, das gilt natürlich alleine ein für ihr Fernsehprogramm. Das heißt, das Internet selber hat dafür natürlich auch nichts. Ist natürlich auch schwierig, wie soll man das unter den vielen Internetangeboten aufteilen? Das sehe ich auch ein. Nur, da müsste man auch ehrlich sein und sagen, es ist nach wie vor natürlich eine alte GEZ-Gebühr, die nur auf neuem Wege erhoben wird. Es ist in dem Sinne keine Medienabgabe. Das Zweite ist, dass sie nach wie vor 17,98 Euro betragen soll, so wie es jetzt aussieht. Also genauso hoch wie vorher, obwohl die Bemessungsgrundlage viel größer ist.
Beziehungsweise höher, wenn man nur Ferraio bezahlt hat.
Denn es ist sogar höher, genau. Nur, es wurde mittlerweile ja schon ausgerechnet, dass ARD und ZDF durch diese Änderung statt jetzt 7,2 Milliarden künftig 8,6 Milliarden Euro einnehmen mit so einer Umstellung, weil viel mehr Leute bezahlen. Das heißt, 1,4 Milliarden Euro nehmen sie mehr ein. Das ist fast der gesamte Jahreszahl des zweiten deutschen Fernsehens. Und ich möchte gerne mal wissen, wo geht dieses Geld eigentlich hin? Was ist damit verbunden? Wird das einfach nur so eingesagt? Oder gibt es da auch irgendwelche Vorgaben von Seiten des Gesetzgebers, zu sagen, also wenn ihr jetzt schon so viel mehr Geld einnehmt, denn verzichtet wenigstens auf Werbung und Sponsoring, was sie ja auch nicht wollen, wird es ja auch weiterhin geben. Oder steckt es zumindest wirklich nur in hochwertiges Programm. Und wir geben euch da ganz klare Vorgaben, wofür dieses Geld auch verwendet werden soll. Davon hört man überhaupt nichts. Und das dritte, was ich sehr merkwürdig finde, diese Abgabe soll erst ab 2013 gelten, also in drei Jahren. Und wenn ich mir so anschaue, was es für Umwälzungen gibt, im technischen Bereich beim Fernsehen. Wir haben schon darüber gesprochen. Und ich weiß gar nicht, wo das Fernsehen möglicherweise schon 2013 stehen wird. Da kann sich unglaublich viel verändern bis dahin. Vielleicht ist dann auch diese Abgabe gar nicht mehr zeitgemäß und ist auch vielleicht schon längst überholt. Also es sind unglaublich lange Zeiträume, die da immer vergehen, was ich auch nicht ganz verstehen kann. Ich meine, wenn irgendeine Steuer erhoben wird, dauert es auch noch ein paar Monate, dann wird sie erhoben oder erhöht. Warum muss es bei dir in diesem Bereich so lange dauern? Warum kann man nicht zum 1. Januar 2011 das einführen? Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das so kompliziert ist.
Na, ist es nicht vielleicht die GEZ-Abwicklung und die entsprechenden Sozialpläne, die da entworfen werden müssen, um die Drückerkolonnen dann auch rechtzeitig in die private Wirtschaft zu entlassen, damit sie wieder Zeitungsabonnements verkaufen?
Ja, ich höre ja sogar nach wie vor immer noch, dass die GEZ sogar noch weiter existieren soll. Ich weiß gar nicht, wofür die denn noch gut sein soll. Keine Ahnung. Also eine richtige Abschaffung.
Vielleicht wird das dann die Behörde, die diese Medien-Einnahme verbucht.
Ja, aber das würde ja eigentlich...
Da muss ja ein Stempel irgendwo drauf machen.
Das würde eigentlich ja über die Steuer laufen, das muss ja nicht jeder irgendwie... Ne, das...
Bin ich jetzt nicht im Bilde darüber, wie das konkret geplant ist, aber soweit ich weiß, ist eine Vermischung mit Steuern so nicht vorgesehen. Aber jetzt berühren wir auf dünnen Eis.
Ja, ich auch. Also wie es konkret aussehen soll, weiß ich nicht. In Frankreich gibt es das ja schon.
Also 2013 ist klar. In Internet-Jahren stehen da schon wieder so zwei, drei Revolutionen an. Gut, welche das jetzt sind, das wissen wir auch nicht. Aber was natürlich sehr interessant ist, ist das Verhältnis von Fernsehen zu Internet. Während das vor einigen Jahren noch gar nicht so richtig wahrgenommen wurde, gab es zumindest ein paar Lichtblicke. Also Tagesschau als Redaktion habe ich jetzt als recht innovativ wahrgenommen. Ich habe auch so die Eindruck gehabt, das kam so ein bisschen aus der Systemadministrationskanzel heraus. Da scheinen sich ein paar Freaks eingelagert zu haben, die da einfach den rechten Blick haben und in der Lage waren, das sozusagen von hinten heraus auch ein bisschen voranzubringen. Trotz alledem leidet das Ganze ja immer noch unter der Gesetzgebung, bis hin zu diesen absurden Vorgängen, wie jetzt gerade vor ein paar Tagen, dass halt die Inhalte wieder vom Netz genommen werden. Die sowieso schon nicht immer da waren.
Ja, das verstehe ich auch nicht ganz. Lieferlage sehen halt da eine starke Konkurrenz bei ihren privaten Informationsangeboten. Aber ich meine, ich finde es zum Beispiel toll, wenn alle Tagesschauungen, die es jemals gab, bis seit 1950, wenn es die alle im Internet abrufbar gäbe, es gäbe kein besseres Rechercheinstrument für Journalisten und auch für Historiker sogar mittlerweile, als das.
Vor allem, es würde wahrscheinlich nur ein paar Tage dauern und die Dinger wären komplett untertitelt.
Ja, natürlich.
Also wenn man das so crowdsourced.
Genau, oder auch die Tagesschau-App. Da wurde sich ja auch aufgeregt fürs iPhone. Die Tagesschau-App, dass gesagt wurde, warum ist die kostenlos? Natürlich muss die kostenlos sein. Ich zahle doch bereits die EZ-Gebühren dafür. Was wäre das für ein Skandal, wenn Tagesschau jetzt käme und sagen, wir wollen noch 80 Cent dafür haben für die Tagesschau-App. Das wäre doch ein Ding. Das geht in die falsche Richtung. Nein, wir haben ja alle bereits mit unseren Gebührengeldern dafür bezahlt, für diese Inhalte, also gehören die uns auch. Insofern müssen wir sie auch abrufen dürfen im Internet, und zwar auch noch über einen längeren Zeitraum. Das geht in die falsche Richtung, das stimmt.
Was kann man da machen?
Ja, dass man es entsprechend ändert.
Wo ist sozusagen der Knopf, auf den man drücken muss? Wer sind die Personen, die letzten Endes beeinflusst werden müssen?
In der Politik natürlich. Die haben das ja so vorgegeben.
Ja gut, aber ich habe auch nicht so den Eindruck, dass jetzt die Medienhäuser selber, also die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, ausreichend Druck machen. Also wenn ich, jetzt bin ich wieder mal der Fernsehsender, wenn sie mir gekommen wären mit, naja hier, aber was ihr da im Internet habt, das müsst ihr löschen. Ich meine, den hätte ich doch an den Marsch geblasen. Also da stellt man doch, da setzt man doch, da schaltet man doch mal einen Tag lang das Fernsehen aus.
Ja, aber da ist die Verkrickung von Politik und Fernsehen auch viel zu stark. Also ich meine, das hat man ja auch letztes Jahr bei der Bundestagswahl gesehen, dass Frau Merkel und Herr Steinmeier lediglich bereit waren, sich mit sich selbst zu unterhalten in einem Kanzlerduell. Also die Kanzlerin unterhält sich mit ihrem Vizekanzler und beide nicht bereit waren, mit der Opposition auch nur in einer einzigen Fernsehsendung zu diskutieren. Grunde genommen hätte Herr Schechter vom ZDF oder auch von der ARD-Leute hätten da wirklich auch öffentlich das einfach knallhart kritisieren müssen. Hätten sagen müssen, so, wir machen jetzt hier eine Diskussionsrunde und hier ist der Stuhl von Frau Merkel und Herrn Steinmeier. Wenn die nicht kommen, lassen wir die beiden Stühle eben leer. Dann kommen eben nur die drei von der Opposition oder keine Ahnung. Aber da hat die Politik wiederum auch von ihrer Seite Druck gemacht. Die öffentlichen Harmonionen und SPD haben besonders viel zu sagen in diesen Gremien, weil sie auch die großen Parteien sind. Und Herr Bränder hat dann ja am Wahltagabends zu Frau Merkel gesagt, Frau Merkel, ich hätte mich sehr darüber gefreut, wenn wir sie auch in einer solchen...
Also Bränder, der Schasse.
Der ehemalige ZDF-Chefredakteur. Genau, da wollte ich jetzt nämlich hinaus. Er war ZDF-Chefredakteur und hat sehr deutlich Kritik an ihr geübt am Wahlabend. Nach der Wahl gab es ihn mit ihr. Da war sie bereit, sich zu diskutieren mit allen, weil die Wahl gelaufen war. Und ich glaube, dass das auch mit zu seiner Ablösung geführt hat. Also das hat sie sich nicht bieten lassen von ihm.
Auch wenn es dann vornehmlich durch Herrn Koch sozusagen...
Ja, gut, der hat dann natürlich das vorangetrieben mit seinem Namen. Auch weil er vielleicht wusste, dass er bald zurücktritt. Hat er ja schon offenbar geplant gehabt, wie er jetzt erzählte. Und so hat er auch nichts mehr zu verlieren gehabt, ne? Ja, das ist öffentlich-rechtliches Fernsehen.
Das heißt, letzten Endes ist das ein Plädoyer für weniger politisches Involvieren. Ich meine, gut, letzten Endes gibt es ja immer noch so das Volk. Ich will jetzt hier nicht so sehr das Demokratiehorn tröten lassen, aber ich frage mich halt auch immer wieder, wenn man so die Dinge beklagt, wo sind so die Türen, die man aufmachen muss, um auch eine Änderung herbeizuführen? Weil sonst sitzt man da die ganze Zeit und beklagt und beklagt sich. Und dann war es das so.
Ja, das ist hier sehr schwierig. Das ist ähnlich schwierig wie mit den Diäten für Politiker. Die Politiker bestimmen auch selbst darüber und wollen auch, dass dich nicht außerhand geben lassen. Das ist halt schwierig, sein eigenes Schicksal selbst zu bestimmen. Da kommst du schwer gegen an.
Na gut, aber ich habe ja mal gemerkt, dass solche Strukturen immer dann ganz schnell lernfähig werden, wenn sie dann die Fälle auch mal wirklich davon schwimmen sehen. So und nicht nur davon erzählt bekommen, dass das morgen mal stattfindet. Auch da ist natürlich jetzt der Einfluss von dem Internet ganz interessant. Weil jetzt hier so unsere eigene kleine Branche, das Podcasting usw. gar nicht so sehr auf den Thron heben, trotzdem sehe ich eine ganze Menge Bewegung von unabhängigen Medien, die eben auch sagen, wie du das vorhin auch schon so formuliert hast, und ich kann das ja für mich auch genauso übernehmen, so dieses Gewinn an Freiheit, der ist so enorm dadurch, dass ich alles selber bestimmen kann, dass die Einschränkungen an Möglichkeiten nicht ausreichend einschränken, dass es mir nicht mehr gefällt. Kompliziert ausgedrückt. Auf jeden Fall habe ich so den Eindruck, dass es eine Welle gibt von Leuten, die im Prinzip die Medienproduktion im Netz komplett neu erfinden. Dabei sind sie erstmal für sich zu entdecken. Jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage, was ergibt sich da draus? Du hast ja gesagt, okay, die Fernsehsender werden sich ändern, was würdest du denn für einen Fernsehen machen, wenn du jetzt, was weiß ich, es klingelt an der Tür und dann kommt jemand an und sagt, hier Herr Kreymeier, hier haben sie mal 20 Millionen Euro. Machen sie auch mal, ja? So, was würdest du machen?
Tja, was würde ich machen? Ich würde zumindest versuchen, den Zuschauer als ernst zu nehmen, als Kunden, als denjenigen, der es am Ende konsumieren muss und nicht zu denken von der Seite der Werbeindustrie oder der Quote. Ich würde einfach versuchen, Kreativität walten zu lassen. Weil das ist natürlich jetzt sehr leicht gesagt, leichter gesagt als getan. Aber ich glaube, wenn das Fernsehen mal wirklich wieder kreative Leute für sich interessieren würde, und das geschieht ja leider nicht, dann würden da auch unglaublich tolle Formate dabei rauskommen. Und gerade auch im Bildungsbereich. Ich meine, die dritten Programme wurden ja mal zum Beispiel gegründet als Schulfernsehen, als Bildungsfernsehen. Ich weiß, ihr könnt sich auch noch daran erinnern, vielleicht in dem dritten Programm, Englisch für Anfänger, für Volkskolleg, Telekolleg und so weiter. Was könnte man heute in Verbindung mit dem Internet für super Geschichten machen? Also setz dich vor deinem Computer, wir starten die Sendung jetzt und löst die Aufgaben oder so. Ja, das geschieht leider alles überhaupt nicht.
Du bist gerade mittendrin hier im Bilanzprogramm. Telekolleg des 21.
Ja, finde ich schon. Ich verstehe nicht, warum das nicht gemacht wird. Ich meine, Sturm der Liebe muss man nicht 14-mal am Tag wiederholen in dem dritten Programm. Das ist kein Bildungsfernsehen. Ja, wie gesagt, ich würde versuchen, ein kreatives Fernsehen zu machen. Ich würde versuchen, den Zuschauer ernst zu nehmen, ihn nicht abzuzocken. Aber ob das funktionieren würde, weiß ich nicht. Vielleicht werde ich nach einem Vierteljahr pleite. Ich weiß es nicht.
Kennst du denn noch andere gute Beispiele von Fernsehen im Netz, wo Leute auch versuchen, ein ähnliches Programm zu starten, was sich in irgendeiner Form mit der Medienlandschaft vielleicht auch kritisch auseinandersetzt, außer dem, was du machst?
Ja, also ich finde Retro-TV sehr schön. Das ist halt nur ein reiner Rückblick aufs alte Fernsehen, aber das ist sehr liebevoll gemacht. Das die sind auch für den Grimme Online Award nominiert.
Wie auch dein Programm, das haben wir noch gar nicht erwähnt.
Ja, wobei, wenn das jetzt nicht ausgestrahlt wird, war es wahrscheinlich schon.
Da wissen wir es schon, aber ich bin ganz froh, dass wir jetzt noch den Tag vorher gehabt haben. Da ist sozusagen die Spannung noch komplett man spürt sich völlig in der Luft. Jaja, aber morgen ist dann sozusagen da die Verkündung, wer den Online Award gewinnt. Alles Gute auf jeden Fall dafür. Aber RetroTV ist sozusagen direkt auf Konkurrenz oder sind die in der anderen Abteilung? Nee, in der gleichen.
Nee, das ist diese Unterhaltung, ich bin Information. Beim Publikumspreis sind sie in Konkurrenz. Das sind ja alle Seiten. Ja, das ist sehr schön gemacht. Es gibt den, ach, wie heißt der jetzt? Der, der hat sich immer BA bei, da hat er sich immer genannt, bei YouTube. Der macht das mittlerweile exklusiv für Cicero online. David Hanash heißt der, genau. Der setzt sich auch ähnlich wie ich mit Fernsehen-Inhalten auseinander. Bei ihm sind sie aber, glaube ich, ausschließlich die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen. Aber er ist bei ihm so ein bisschen trockener. Also er macht das nicht satirisch, sondern er macht es mehr so als trockener Kommentator. Und das ist aber auch ganz schön gemacht. Ja, es gibt natürlich, also jetzt nicht ein Bewegt-Bild, sondern im schriftlichen Bereich nicht jede Menge Beispiele. Stefan Niggemeier und Bildblock und wie die alle heißen. Das sind natürlich tolle Medienseiten. Was Bewegt-Bild angeht, muss man natürlich ein bisschen auch das Know-how haben, um das machen zu können. Insofern, aber das wird sich doch hoffentlich weiterentwickeln. Darf ich gerade dagegenhauen. Mal schauen, wie es in den nächsten Jahren weitergeht. Also ich war 2007, als ich angefangen hab, war ich ja so ein Pionier, glaube ich, den Mut zu haben, einfach mal eine Dreiviertelstunde, so eine Folge auch lang sein werden zu lassen. Weil viele haben damals gesagt, ach, bist du verrückt, das muss da maximal drei Minuten länger haben. Die Leute haben keine Geduld, sich das anzuschauen. Die schalten das sofort wieder ab. Und das halte ich natürlich für Unsinn. Weil wenn der Inhalt relevant ist, wenn er interessant ist, gucken sie das auch eine Dreiviertelstunde. Ja, das kommt dazu. Gut, wir haben da natürlich auch, denn wiederum haben wir diese Springfunktion da eingeführt, dass du auch zum Beitrag direkt springen kannst, wenn, wenn und so. Das haben wir dann auch gemacht. Aber jetzt zu sagen, es muss alles so Häppchenweise passieren. Einer hat mal gesagt, das wäre ja YouTube-Niveau, wenn ich es so machen würde. Und das finde ich eigentlich ein sehr schönes Bild, weil Häppchen-Clips haben wir nun jede Menge im Netz. Und wenn man sich auch ein bisschen davon abhebt, ist es ja auch ganz gut.
Auf jeden Fall. Ich denke, ein langes Programm ist ja hier auch mal angesagt. Warte mal auf die Sendung, die bei mir mal den drei Stunden-Rahmen bricht.
Wir reden ja auch schon eine ganze Zeit.
Das ist ja für CRE-Verhältnisse alles noch Pille-Palle. Radio hast du noch gar nicht erwähnt. Was hast du denn da für ein Verhältnis?
Radio höre ich nur morgens unter der Dusche und beim Abwaschen. Sonst bin ich kein großer Radio-Hörer, muss ich ganz ehrlich gestehen.
Bisschen visuell geprägt.
Ja, ja. Und da höre ich mir entweder... Soll ich jetzt Radiosender nennen oder...
Nee, ich wollte nur mal so fragen, weil wir reden ja hier so ein bisschen über zukünftige Formate und das Internet. So nur Radio ist jetzt so noch nicht gefallen, aber wenn du nicht weißt, was du dran hast.
Ich habe auch mal beim Radio was gemacht, Praktikant und so, und dann auch als Freiberufler am Anfang. Ich war damals bei OK Radio hier in Hamburg, wo denn auch so Leute wie Oliver Geissen und so damals noch Moderatoren waren, aber Radio ist nicht mein Medium, muss ich einfach so sagen.
Okay, heute geht es ja auch um Fernsehen. Richtig, ja. Kennst du den Film Fri Rainer, Dein Fernseher lügt?
Natürlich, habe ich auch darauf hingewiesen damals in einer Folge, habe auch den DVD.
Schöner Film von Hans Weingartner, der so die schöne Idee hat, dass so einer kleine Gruppe von Aktivisten gelingt, das Quoten-Erfassungssystem, was ja auch ein bisschen merkwürdig ist, deswegen komme ich eigentlich auch drauf, das mal so weit zu hacken, da technische Maßnahmen zu machen und dann sozusagen nur noch Dinge, die Qualität haben, in der Quoten-Gunst anzubefeuern mit dem Ergebnis, dass Deutschland auf einmal wohlgebildet und alle nur noch auf Qualitätsfernsehen aussehen. Schönes Bild. Was geht dir da los den Kopf, wenn da irgendwie solche, also die Quoten hast du ja nur auch schon einige Male erwähnt und 17 Millionen Leute schauen zu und so weiter. Wir wissen alle, dass irgendwie ein Bruchteil dieser Leute tatsächlich in irgendeiner Form erfasst wird und das ist ja auch nur so Couch-Potatoes, wo so ein Device im Wohnzimmer steht.
Ja, das war ja auch in dem Film sehr gut wiedergegeben und sehr gut recherchiert, dass eben gesagt wurde, es gibt bestimmte Gruppen, die gar nicht von der GfK erfasst werden, also für der Gesellschaft, für Konsumforschung, die diese Messung ja durchführt. Studenten, glaube ich, sind nicht dabei, Ausländer sind nicht dabei oder Leute mit Migrationshintergrund sozusagen. Und deswegen kann es auch sein, dass die Quoten ohnehin ziemlich verzerrt sind. Man weiß gar nicht, ob es wirklich repräsentativ ist, was da erhoben wird. Und ich weiß auch nicht, ob nicht heute auch schon gewisse Manipulationen vorgenommen werden. Wer weiß das denn? Ich meine, wenn da ein paar Millionen Euro fließen.
Also mein Freund Heugi hat mal gepetzt, er hätte jemanden gekannt, der so ein Gerät hatten, als er mal im Fernsehen war, hat er ihn gezwungen einzuschalten. Und auf einmal waren alle ganz erstaunt über die guten Quoten. Ja, weil einer schon so viel Unterschied gemacht hat, das ist halt so eine Box, sind halt irgendwie dann schnell mal einstellige Prozentänderungen und...
Ja, das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Ja, ich meine, es wäre doch ein Leichtes, irgendwie ein paar Leute irgendwie da rauszubekommen, vielleicht, die so ein Gerät haben und sagen, pass mal auf, ich zahle dir hier ein paar tausend Euro, guck doch mal unsere Sendung oder so. Ich weiß es nicht, kann ich gar nicht beweisen, aber dass das natürlich viel Potenzial für Manipulationen im Grunde gibt, liegt ja auf der Hand, nicht? Aber es ist erstaunlich, dass die Privaten selber es aber offenbar so akzeptieren als System.
Hauptsache man einigt sich aber eins, das ist wahrscheinlich deren Ding. Hauptsache man weiß, wie man es in den Griff kriegt. Trotzdem gibt es ja auch wirklich Sendungen, wo ganz offensichtlich ist, dass sich die Leute kollektiv darauf stürzen. Ich merke das als nicht-fernseh-Mensch, merkt man das auf Twitter immer sonntags, wenn dann irgendwie Tatort anfängt. Und auf einmal der Anteil von Tatort-bezogenen Tweets von Menschen, deren mentale Einschätzung dieser Welt ich sehr schätze, auch dann immer noch. Also nicht, dass ich der Meinung bin, dass ich das jetzt Tatort-Gucken doof mache, das ist nicht das, was ich sagen will. Ich stelle einfach mal fest, auf einmal gibt es dann so eine Art Lagerfeuer im Internet, wo sie dann alle so ihre Hände dran wärmen, mal gucken, wie der Tatort diese Woche so ist. Gibt es da noch andere Beispiele solcher Sendungsinstitutionen, die so einen ähnlichen Charakter versprühen?
Werden das sicherlich nach wie vor, hat immer noch hervorragende Quoten, wobei die auch auf dem absteigenden Ast sind ein Stück weit, also er unterschreitet immer öfter die zweistellige Millionen-Quote der Gottschalk. Früher hat er so locker sie 13 bis 15 Millionen gehabt.
Ist der eigentlich immer noch blond?
Der ist immer noch blond, ja.
Wie alt ist der jetzt?
Der ist 60 geworden im Mai. Ja, viele regen sich über ihn auf und so. Aber ich glaube, das ist jemand, den man vermissen wird, wenn er nicht mehr da ist. Weil das ist noch so einer vom alten Schlag der Moderatoren-Generationen, die man noch vermissen wird, glaube ich. Und die Sendung wetten das. Ja, sie ist halt auch ein Ritual im Grunde genommen. Die Leute gucken sie es einfach an, weil sie wissen, das gucken ganz viele heute Abend. Also will ich auch mitreden können. Auch wenn die Sendung selber vielleicht nicht so dolle ist. Und bei der Tagesschau ist es natürlich auch ähnlich. 8 Uhr wird der Fernseher angemacht, bei vielen jetzt auf die Tagesschau.
Also auf Thomas Gottschalk einhauen ist natürlich einfacher. Aber ich mich so erinnere, wie der mal angefangen hat. Der war ja extrem innovativ unterwegs. Er hat seinerzeit, war das im bayerischen Fernsehen, die Sendung Tele-Spiele gemacht, wo die dann wirklich die Leute über das Telefon-Pong gespielt haben. Stimme wird lauter, der Schläger geht nach oben, ganz großartig fand ich das. Weil das war wirklich außergewöhnlich. Das war ja im Prinzip dieses Hörer-Beteiligen, haben wir ja unser interaktives Fernsehen im Prinzip auch gehabt.
Also man hat im Grunde genommen interaktives Fernsehen zu einem Zeitpunkt gemacht, wo es noch gar nicht ausgereift war. Heutzutage, wo man die Möglichkeiten hätte, macht man es nicht mehr. Oder man bescheißt eben die Leute mit teuren Telefonnummern. Ja, weiß ich auch nicht.
Außerdem hätten wir das. Was gibt es noch für Lagerfeuer, um das sich alle scharen? Also die auch so regelmäßig stattfinden. Jetzt nicht so Weltmeisterschaft und so. Das hatten wir ja schon. Das sind so diese ganz großen Dinge. Aber was sind so die kleinen, also was sind so die Geheimtipps? Darauf wollte ich eigentlich so ein bisschen hinaus.
Na, dann wäre es ja keine Geheimtipps, wenn es Lagerfeuer ist. Den kennst du ja, den gucken sie ja alle.
Hört doch keiner zu.
Es gibt da nicht mehr so viele. Also das ist wirklich, das ist sehr übersichtlich. Also RTL schafft das mit DSDS, weil sie eine sehr starke Allianz mit der Bild haben. Die Bild-Zeitung.
Aber das ist doch nicht zu vertragen, oder? Also ich meine, mir wird da, also ich kriege da wirklich physikalische Probleme.
Also diese Sendung gucken im Schnitt ungefähr 7 Millionen Zuschauer. Bei den jungen Kundengenerationen sind das Marktanteile von 40 Prozent oder mehr. Das ist schon mit einer der Top-Sendungen im deutschen Fernsehen, muss man wirklich sagen. Warum auch immer.
Na von der Quantität her.
Ja, ja sicher.
Darauf wollte ich jetzt hinaus. Weil bei diesem Tatort, da geht es ja nicht um die Masse, sondern mir geht es um dieses Involviert-Sein. Also dieses Tatort ist für alle spannend. Was wird dieses Mal passieren? Wie wird es gelungen sein oder nicht? Da ist dann irgendwie so eine Kritik der Nähe am Start. Die SDS fällt bei mir jetzt überhaupt nicht in diese Kategorie rein. Das mögen sich vielleicht viele Leute anschauen und alle zum Schreien bringen und was weiß ich. Aber ich habe immer vom Charakter dieser Sendung, habe ich immer Angst, dass danach alle auf die Straße gehen und sich gegenseitig erschießen. Weil das einfach so aggressiv ist.
Aber ich gehe mir selber auch zu, ich habe es mir selber dann auch letztendlich angeschaut. Weil man ist natürlich auch als Fernsehkritiker natürlich, aber man denkt sich dann ja doch, naja Gott.
Marcel Reich-Ranitzki wird jetzt schön einen Satz zugeschrieben, wissen Sie, als Kritiker muss ich mich mit so viel Dreck befassen. Das geht ja doch auch so, oder?
Ja, ist richtig.
Wie machst du.
Das? Na ja, im Hinterkopf hab ich ja meinen Magazin und natürlich klatsch ich auch in die Hände, wenn irgendwas Blödes passiert und denke so ach super, das wird doch gleich verwendet für die nächste Sendung. Insofern kann es auch spaßig sein und schön sein, sich Trash anzugucken, wenn man es unter journalistischen Gesichtspunkten sich anschaut.
Schlimmer ist auch, es gibt auch gute Beispiele in deiner Sendung. Also wenn es auch nicht vornehmlich um gute Beispiele geht, was sind denn so die besten guten Beispiele, an die du dich so erinnerst?
Also ich fand diese Oslo-Show eine sehr schöne Castingshow, weil sie wirklich sehr minimalistisch sich auf die Musik konzentriert hat. Die Kandidaten wurden keins der Weise durch den Dreck gezogen von der Boulevardpresse, mit Schutz des Senders auch noch, nach dem Motto, wir suchen die Kandidaten schon danach aus, wer möglichst viel Scheiße im Leben erlebt hat. Sondern da ging es um die Musik und das war eine sehr schöne, niveauvolle Sendung und die hat mir wirklich gut gefallen. Das habe ich auch gelobt. Ich habe einen Beitrag gemacht, wo ich diese Sendung mit DSDS direkt verglichen habe. Das ist ein gutes Beispiel. Es gab mal kürzlich bei Hard Aber Fair, das ist eine Sendung, da schwankt es immer sehr. Das ist eine nötige Talk-Sendung mit Flank Plasberg, wo es auch sehr gute Sendungen gab. Es gab zum Beispiel mal einen Abend, da hatte das erste Programm einen kritischen Fernsehfilm über Scientology gebracht und im Anschluss daran gab es die Diskussion darüber bei Hard Aber Fair mit einem Scientologen dabei, was es im Fernsehen bisher so gut wie noch nie gegeben hat, weil es wurde immer über die gesprochen, aber nie mit denen. Und obwohl das natürlich ein Risiko war, hat man es sehr gut gelöst, weil die Redaktion sehr gut vorbereitet war von der Sendung. Und das war wirklich ein richtig toller Niveau voller Fernsehabend, weil er sich sowohl fiktiv mit diesem Fernsehfilm, aber auch hinterher real in der Sendung mit diesem Thema auseinandergesetzt hat. Das hat mir auch sehr gut gefallen zum Beispiel. Ja, ansonsten soll ich jetzt weitere lobende Beispiele nennen oder?
Können wir denn noch welche einfallen? Es ist ja erstaunlich, dass es welche gibt.
Ja, doch, doch. Also es gibt, ich finde bei ProSieben ist man auch immer so, dass man im Comedy-Bereich sehr offenbar auf Prestige achtet. Also so Sendungen wie Kalkoves Mattscheibe lief ja auch bei ProSieben. Jetzt läuft es dann nicht mehr.
Oder auch eben Stormberg.
Es ist leider, ProSieben hat auch mal kein Interesse mehr, nee.
Das war aber auch wirklich hervorragend.
Ja, es war hervorragend und er hat es immer gut auf den Punkt gebracht. Und er hat es sich ja auch nicht nehmen lassen, auch ProSieben regelmäßig selbst zu kritisieren, mit den Urigella-Shows und so weiter. Ich weiß nicht, ob es am Ende auch daran gescheitert ist, dass ProSieben jetzt sagt, sorry, jetzt reicht es uns. Ich weiß es nicht.
Das hat aber bei Premiere gestartet, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, ne?
Und da hat er bei öffentlich-rechtlich, bei AAD hat er mal so eine Sports-Sondersendung gemacht, so zwei, drei. Und dann ging er zu ProSieben, ja.
Ich kenne Kreymeier noch so aus ganz alten Zeiten, als er so Teil der Privatradio-Revolution war in Hannover, bei FFN.
Frühstücksradio.
Das Frühstücksradio, ganz großartig. Da hat ja irgendwie die CDU quasi diesen Privatsender auf den Weg gebracht und alle haben schon so die Hände an den Kopf gehalten. Und dann haben sie sich gedacht, oh Gott, praise for impact. Und dann startete dieser Sender in einer Frische und Großartigkeit, dass man sich nur noch wundern konnte. Es dauerte irgendwie zwei Wochen und kein Laden in Hannover spielte noch irgendwas anderes. Ich habe damals in Hannover gewunst, deswegen habe ich das irgendwie alles live in der Farbe mitbekommen. Aber dieses Frühstücksradio-Team, das strahlte halt irgendwie über alles. Und dann halt Kalkofer und diese ganzen anderen, wie Dieter Wischmeier und so weiter. Das war wirklich eine Generation von großartigen Satirikern, muss man auch sagen. Ja, die auch alle irgendwie ihren Weg gefunden haben.
Ja, bei diesen Sender heutzutage einzuschalten, ich meine, das ist auch nicht mehr la-la-ra. Ja, im Fernsehen ist es ja genauso. Ich meine, es gab in den 90ern auch bei RTL und Sat1, da gab es eben wunderbare Comedy wie RTL Samstagnacht mit Wiegald Bohning und Olli Dietrich den Zwei-Stühle-eine-Meinung. Das ist doch legendär. Oder die Wochen-Show auf Sat1, die ja so ein bisschen erinnerte an die gute alte Rudi's-Tages-Show, wo man so die Politiker auch durch den Kakao zog und so. Ja, das war klar, da waren aber auch immer noch wirklich kreative Köpfe dabei und die wurden auch entsprechend dann auch finanziell ausgestattet, dass die auch bezahlt werden konnten. Heutzutage nimmt das Fernsehen dieses Geld nicht mehr in die Hand, wahrscheinlich auch, weil es das Geld nicht mehr hat.
Ich meine, die Zahl der kreativen Köpfte dürfte ja nicht geringer gewesen sein. Wo sind die denn jetzt?
Im Internet, vermute ich mal. Wobei die natürlich wiederum das Fernsehen als Hilfsmittel haben und wiederum nur mit eigenen Hilfsmitteln arbeiten können. Dadurch ist es vielleicht qualitativ nicht so, ganz so wie im Fernsehen. Ja, insofern ist es eigentlich schade, dass sich Kreativität und Fernsehen mittlerweile so getrennt haben und zwei verschiedene Wege gehen, weil eigentlich gemeinsam wäre es ja eigentlich das Große.
Verpasste Chancen sozusagen. Wo geht's denn hin?
Wo geht's, ja.
Muss man jetzt machen, wenn man kreativer Kopf ist und hier gerade zuhört und eigentlich muss man jetzt mal einen Fernsehsender gründen, oder? Also so im Internet mein ich.
Ein Fernsehsender im Internet? Wie meinst du das jetzt? Also du meinst einfach...
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie ich das meine, um ehrlich zu sein. Aber ich meine, wir haben ja schon festgestellt, dass es durchaus, also das kann auch alles durchaus unterhaltsamen Charakter haben. Die ganzen kreativen Köpfe sind sowieso im Internet und es interessieren sich nicht mehr für das alte Fernsehen. Na ja, wenn ich da irgendwie zwei und zwei zusammenzähle.
Ja, so ist das ja. Genau. Und wie gesagt, es sind ja auch schon viele kreative Sachen im Internet. Gibt doch jede Menge. Also ich hab ja auch schon einige Gastbeitrag-Autoren, die ich jetzt schon mehrmals bei mir hatte in der Sendung. Also zum Beispiel diesen Emanuel Koch, der hat einen wunderbaren Beitrag gemacht über Schnitte im Fernsehen, weil bei Filmen immer Szenen gekürzt werden, irgendwie Schnitte, Spielfilme gekürzt werden. Und ich hab dieses Thema auch schon lange auf der Agenda gehabt, hab gedacht, wie mach ich das denn los? Wie zeig ich den Leuten etwas, was man nicht gesehen hat, weil es rausgeschnitten war? Ist natürlich schwierig umzusetzen. Und er hat es dann halt mit Animationen gemacht, so eine Schere, die aus dem Fernseher rauskommt und am Film rumschnippelt oder am Zuschauer rumschnippelt. Und das war unglaublich kreativ und toll gemacht.
Machen die Leute denn eigentlich diese Beiträge sowieso? Und du sammelst sie nur ein, nachdem sie schon im Netz rumgegangen sind?
Nein, nein.
Oder werden diese Sachen jetzt wirklich nur deshalb produziert, weil es da ein Magazin gibt?
Also meine ganz klare Vorgabe, ich hab ja eine kleine Informationsseite auch, Gastbeitrag und so weiter, ist klar, das darf nicht vorher woanders wo gelaufen sein. Also so viel Exklusivität möchte ich schon gerne haben. Wenn es bei mir veröffentlicht wurde, können sie es auch bei YouTube hochladen. Das ist mir denn egal. Aber die erste Quelle muss bei mir sein. Aber wird auch so akzeptiert. Dafür kriegen sie ja auch 50 Euro Honorar. Ich mein, zwar immerhin auch einen kleinen Geldbetrag dafür, ist nicht viel, aber für jemanden, der jetzt vielleicht noch Schüler ist oder so, aber sich mit Videoschnitt schon ganz gut auskennt, ist es ja schon...
Das ist auch eine Anerkennung. Das heißt, die Existenz eines solchen Aggregationsformats, Magazin, bringt Leute eigentlich dazu, kreativ zu werden. Kann man sagen. Vielleicht ist das ja schon sozusagen der erste Schritt zum Sender. Weil im Prinzip bist du ja einer. Bist ja Fernsehkritik TV. Kann man zwar als Sendung begreifen, aber im Prinzip ist das ja ein Kosmos für sich, in dem dann sozusagen Leute ihre Sendung platzieren können, wenn sie denn wollen und seinen Ansprüchen.
Wenn es gut gemacht ist, klar. Sicherlich. Also handwerklich ist es mir schon wichtig. Also ich sag mal so zwei, drittel oder vielleicht sogar noch mehr aller eingereichten Gastbattliche kann ich nicht nehmen, weil sie zu schlecht sind. Ton ist zu schlecht, Schnitt ist zu schlecht. Oder Leute, die bringen die Message einfach nicht rüber. Da war es einfach schon vom journalistischen Aspekt her nicht gut gemacht. Aber ich gebe jedem natürlich Feedback und auch sehr ausführlich und sage, pass mal auf, das und das und das müsstest du verbessern. Und viele werfen dann das Handtuch und sagen, ja, nee. Und einige haben aber den Ehrgeiz, es noch mal zu versuchen. Und noch mal und noch mal. Ich habe zum Beispiel jetzt in Folge 49 einen Beitrag gehabt von jemandem, der hat über die Apple-Geschichte im Fernsehen was gemacht. Das ist ein Beitrag, den habe ich mit ihm ein Stück weit zusammen gemacht, weil die erste Version, die war mir viel zu langweilig. Und ich habe gesagt, pass mal auf, du musst hier, das musst du ein bisschen zusammenkürzen und mach mal hier noch und da und hier. Und am Ende ist ein Beitrag rausgekommen, der auch ganz gut ankam bei den Zuschauern. Also insofern, wenn ich da Potenzial sehe, dann mach ich es auch mit den Leuten ein Stück weit noch zusammen. Weil ich bin ja interessiert daran, wenn ich sehe, das ist eine gute Story und das ist eine gute Geschichte. Und das hat Potenzial, will ich ja das auch gerne in der Sendung haben. Aber einige haben auch von vornherein gleich sofort als ersten. Also der ist ja schon erwähnt, der Manuel Koch mit seinen Animationsfilmen. Er war ab sofort ein Volltreffer, gleich von Anfang an. Da musste sich nichts mehr dran ändern, hat mir gut gefallen.
Ja, das ist schon richtig, erinnere mich so halb das, war ganz beeindruckend.
Ja, er hat ja auch, ich habe ja auch zu meiner Spendenaktion so ein kleinen Trick-Film gehabt, wo ich noch mal in Kurzform, das war auch von ihm zum Beispiel. Der hatte ja auch, hab ich natürlich gefragt, ob er das machen würde, hat er sofort gemacht. Der war auch sehr schön.
Ja, die Spenden, also so finanziert sich im Prinzip das Programm, sehe ich das richtig?
Nee, Spenden habe ich jetzt nur gesammelt für diese Geschichte mit der Juristerei, weil ich da in der Tat 12.000 Euro mal ebenso an Gerichts- und Anwaltskosten zu zahlen hatte oder auch noch zu habe. Ich habe noch einige Kostenbescheide, habe ich noch nicht bekommen. Aber das Geld hatte ich natürlich jetzt nicht mal auf der hohen Kante. Ansonsten, Spenden gelegentlich mal sind nicht so viele. Ich finanziere mich über Werbung, über gescheiterte Banner und über...
Also auf der Webseite, nicht im Programm?
Vorweg, zu Beginn einer Folge habe ich manchmal einen Werbespot, der so 15, 20 Sekunden lang ist.
Auch im Podcast?
Nee, im Podcast nicht. Deswegen ist der Podcast und die Quicktime-Wirtung doch immer zwei Tage später erst drauf, weil ich will, dass die Leute heute erst mal alle die Werbung gucken, wo sie sich den Podcast unternehmen.
So trägt sich das auch?
So trägt es sich einigermaßen. Ich mache ab und zu noch mal Kleinigkeiten, mal so journalistisch nebenbei, aber das ist mittlerweile meine Haupteinnahmequelle.
Und Flatter hat jetzt gerade Einzug gehalten bei dir?
Flatter? Ich weiß, ich habe noch keine Ergebnisse bekommen. Ich kann nicht einschätzen, was das bringt. Ich weiß es nicht. Keine Ahnung. Ich bin gespannt.
Ja, haben wir etwas ganz Tolles vergessen zu erwähnen, was noch auf dem Herzen liegt, was man so mitteilen muss. Wir haben so einige Sachen jetzt auch rausgelassen, die man noch hätte ansprechen können, was weiß ich, so Sachen wie Nachrichten und überhaupt so diese ganze sonstige Restrealität. Wie sieht da...
Ein weites Feld.
Es ist ein sehr weites Feld, soweit wir es jetzt gar nicht treiben. Irgendwas, was dir so auf der Seele brennt. Was du vielleicht so motivierend auch so in den potenziellen Fernsehproduzenten von morgen hineinbringen möchtest. Qualitätssätzlich durch, hast du mal vorhin gesagt?
Richtig, ja. So ist das.
Aber man hat nicht immer den Eindruck, oder? Nee. Oder doch? Wie denn jetzt? Quote oder Qualität?
Ja, beim Fernsehen ist es momentan noch eher eben die Quote als die Qualität. Weil man mit Qualität, geht man auch immer ein Risiko ein. Qualität kostet Geld, Qualität kostet Zeit. Man kann nicht Qualität übers Bein brechen. Man muss vielleicht auch eine Sendung entwickeln, damit sie irgendwann qualitativ hochwertig wird. Das war bei Fernsehkredit TV auch so. Die erste Folge war handwerklich natürlich schlecht. Ich war als Moderator noch vollkommen unsicher. Ich musste auch das ein bisschen selbst beibringen. Sicherer zu sprechen, nicht bei jedem zweiten Wort eher zu sagen und so. Und so muss man im Fernsehen im Grunde genommen auch die Geduld haben und den langen Atem haben, um sowas zu entwickeln. Das hat das Fernsehen halt nicht. Wenn die Quote nicht stimmt oder wenn es von vornherein sowieso zu teuer ist, wird das nicht gemacht. So, das ist das Problem. Ich weiß da keine Lösung für. Ich kann nur hoffen, dass da irgendwann eine Generation von Leuten wieder ans Ruder kommt, die vielleicht einfach von vornherein anders denkt darüber und mit anderen Ansatz daran geht. Die jetzige Generation der Medienmanager, das ist, ja, es gab mal ein Buch, das hieß Nieten in den Nadelstreifen. Da geht es so allgemein um die Wirtschaft, aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass die über den Fernsehen auch einzugehalten haben.
Verstehe. Na gut, Holger, vielen Dank.
Gerne.
Ich denke, da können wir es jetzt hier mal einen Punkt machen. Das war das Gespräch, was ich gesucht habe. Mal so ein bisschen in die Breite diskutiert ohne jetzt hier wieder als Leben des Manuals zu dienen. Ich denke, bei Fernsehen kann man sich auch irgendwie auch totreden. Trotzdem, es gibt da auch viel Gutes zu entdecken. Und vielleicht ist es auch wirklich das Medium, was demnächst mal revolutioniert gehört. Meine ganzen Produktionskosten sind jetzt für Video- und Audioproduktion an so einen Punkt angekommen, wo man sagen kann, das kann jetzt eigentlich wirklich jeder machen. Und man hat bei Musik gesehen, was das ausgelöst hat, als das jeder machen konnte. Und dementsprechend mit den Publikationsplattformen, die jetzt zur Verfügung stehen, sind irgendwie die Karten neu gemischt.
Ich danke dir auch.
Und ja, das wars. Ausgabe 157 von Chaosradio Express. Wo ich in Urlaub fahre, werde ich hier noch so einiges versuchen, auf die Platte zu spülen. Also bleibt angeschnallt, es geht weiter. Und wie immer, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und fürs Kommentieren der Sendung und überhaupt für das ganze Feedback und die guten Tipps, die ihr immer für mich übelst habt. Muss ich mich auch mal für bedanken. Und ja, bleibt dran. Bis zum nächsten Chaosradio Express.